welcome to the just pearly things
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not a relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from them than if you're
flat right here's the thing though
no no but but listen though if it goes
so deeper though because I know who
you're talking about and he has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
bat her great body doesn't look good to
a man but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest end is for women for women
so like the women have higher beauty
standards to me yes and that's what's
making women feel like they need to
comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men and women are
more complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all of them and do you think men
are very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women using men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry
him they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last so I I done an only fan I thought
it wasn't like vagina boobs it was
lingerie yeah builds right whatever I
done it and when I finished it I felt
very degraded I felt very like why did I
actually do that now I know there's
girls out there who do that they don't
feel that way that is perfectly fine you
do you you feel the way you feel but me
personally like like in the future how
like when I have kids and all in the
future and if my kids found out about
that they'll probably get bullied in
school there are people like oh your mom
doing this your mom doing that and your
man as well he's not going to if you
don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not a high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that if you guys have any
questions for the panel make sure that
you Super Chat them how much should we
charge to Super Chat a question today
King
20 all right 20 bucks to Super Chat a
question
um and any Super Chat you want red also
if you just have a comment you can send
a Super Chat we will be doing breaks
throughout the show to read those also
guys um our new live show schedule is
Tuesday Thursday and Saturday so make
sure you tune in on those days
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first tier lets you be a part
of our live chat tonight how many likes
to open up the chat King
okay a thousand likes and we can open up
the chat today
um the second tier you get to see our
Discord and our behind the scenes Vlogs
if you want to see me freestyle rap
um sign up for that why are you laughing
what's the joke I don't get the joke I
don't know it's funny
um anyway so the second tier if you want
to see me uh are behind the scene blogs
and our Discord make sure you sign up
for that third tier you get to connect
with me on social media and fourth here
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month how do you get a million
subscribers in a year I will tell you in
the fourth tier
um also guys go follow my Instagram they
took away my first one that is just
pearly things one
also guys we are on Rumble now so I did
do a one-on-one interview with um with
someone on Rumble um that cannot be
aired on YouTube because
yeah I'm even afraid to say their name
on YouTube but if you want to go see
that make sure you go follow um on
Rumble also guys and we're trying to get
to 25
000 subscribers on wife school we have a
new episode coming out um next week so
make sure you go subscribe to Wife
School
also guys um we're going to be doing a
meet up soon in London and in the U.S so
make sure you sign up for our Google
form the link to that should be in the
description
um can you just double check and make
sure it's in there but it should be
um also guys we have one official
pregame page on Instagram if you want to
come on the show all you have to do is
go on my Instagram profile and click on
um it says DM the pregame to come on so
make sure you go message them if you
want to come on
like the video and I think those are all
of our announcements okay hi guys
welcome to the show
um to start we are gonna do your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself so starting here
go around and then we'll do the second
row
okay so my name is femita I'm 26. I'm
single
and a fun fact about me
um I'm an artist I like to create things
um rap right
oh wow I rap too I'm nice I like that
um yeah that's it for now yeah okay go
ahead
my name is Aisha Lee I'm twin no
actually I'm 30. I was 29 last week
Thursday but I'm now officially 30.
happy birthday and
um It's Complicated I'm married on paper
and yeah
you're married on paper but no more
we're growing on our journey so maybe
together maybe not you're like figuring
it out even Good Times okay all right go
ahead
and my name is yusra I'm 26 years old
I'm single and a fun fact about me well
I'm very curious I like to read about uh
metaphysical things
okay
okay hi guys my name is Esther I am 30
years old and I'm single fun fact about
me I've got
19 tattoos counting I'm gonna get more
soon
hi my name is Omar
um I'm 23 years old and
um
fun fact about me I snuck into love
Island show like two years ago made the
headlines and were you snuck in yeah
snuck in wait how
I wasn't supposed to be there yeah so I
I do I do YouTube videos so
um this was like one of the big YouTube
videos I did like two years ago so I'm
two years ago I vlogged basically me
flying over there
um I had like a cameraman and like
vlogged like the whole journey of me
getting in there and like getting behind
the scenes and all the stuff and then
live streamed it as well had like 10 000
viewers on Instagram live
um and then made it to every single
major newspaper front page on in the UK
so yeah did they catch you oh yeah they
caught me obviously you know I was like
I was running around with the camera you
know I was just like yo guys look at
this man like that is so funny yeah they
called me after and then um yeah I got
away with it though so I didn't get
arrested or anything
um it was kind of fun what made you like
were you nervous you'd get arrested no I
didn't really care to be honest I was
like I think I was like 20 21 you know
um houses like I was just like you know
I was trying to get basically this is
when I was like first star on YouTube
and I was like man let me do something
that will actually like get people's
attention you know and I like to do fun
things so I like to do challenges so I
thought it was like no one's ever done
this before
um I thought it'd be kind of fun how it
like you know investigate like when the
security switched time and film it all
and like to just show people exactly
like how to get into places kind of like
into like some high security place and
like you know everyone said I couldn't
do it you know it's funny like and I
just thought you know what I can do this
so why not just film it as well and I
was like you know why not that's genius
that's so funny
um okay um go ahead all right guys
um my name is r19 online or everyone
calls me rush I'm 21 years old I'm
single and a fun fact about me I grew up
in Jamaica yeah
oh uh my name is Kobe I'm 25 years old
I'm in a relationship and fun fact about
me I have four cats
crazy
that's what I'm talking about
um hello everybody I'll go by the name
of God for uh just turned 24 last week
and a fun fact about me is that uh
studied four years in America
so yeah I got a bit of XP over there
um
yeah hi um my name is Mark I go by the
name of the R B singer
um
I'm 44 I would say I'm 34 but
I guess I let the cat out of the bag
um and yeah fun fact a professional
singer uh got my own agency I have my
own company and I and uh yeah man just
grateful to be here man all good
okay so today
we're going to be talking about the
court of public opinion
um so to start I wanted to ask you guys
about Andrew Tate
are you guys fans
um not fans what is your opinion on him
I'm starting here go around that second
row
I think the certain things that he said
that
is pretty questionable
but then
I feel like mostly you know what it is
offense because he
when he became Muslim he became a bit
more
understanding and I feel like that's
where I relate to that in that sense
but certain things was definitely
questionable beforehand what was the
question I feel like it's too direct I
feel like when you want to say something
to a group of people or maybe say
something that maybe could be true
there's ways to say it instead of like
kind of
I don't want to say belittling but
yeah yeah just too direct yeah some
piano can I have an example
an example
I can't think of one on the top of my
head right now do you think I based them
off of The Tick Tock videos by the way
do you because the one thing I always
wonder is like is it more important if
it's true
or is it more important it like how they
say it
um it depends because certain people can
take it in different ways like even if
you are telling someone a good thing it
can lead them the opposite direction
I I feel like you kind of have to sorry
but yeah you kind of have to like
take a pinch yourself
yeah I disagree I think that tough love
is the is the best thing like I think if
you're fat and you're called fat I think
you lose weight quicker
because then you get embarrassed you
know you're like oh darn
you disagree it's okay no my mom
literally broke me up on tough love so I
get that as well but
but sometimes it hurts I don't know what
I mean like but it's like a Band-Aid
ripping up you know you're better well I
didn't hear what you mean because like I
think as a kid when I was like bigger
let's say or you fat kid too yeah I was
a chubby oh yeah me too yeah yeah like I
was trying to lose weight yes
me too did your mom give you Pop-Tarts
that's what my mom did it was like the
cinnamon ones my mom actually fattened
me up yeah yeah she's like she actually
fattened me up and then I'm the one that
gained all the weight and then yeah I
haven't did a person okay
um what what about you what's your
opinion I see you nodding to her
sometimes and to me sometimes so I'm
like which which one is she gonna pick
um I'm not a fan of him okay but um
I'm not a fan of him but I believe
everyone is entitled to their own
opinion
um I agree with you when it comes to
tough love because I feel when we go
through our pain State that's where we
grow more because it's like you're
forced to so
um yeah maybe how he articulates himself
and projects himself may not be the best
way to everyone else but each their own
and um yeah what do you think about the
criminal case I'm going on right now
um do you know much about it or no I
don't know much because when it comes to
the whole social media clout I try not
to be
as get myself too stuck into it because
at dinner everyone's got their own
opinion and we have the right to do with
exactly whatever we want so um yeah
that's what I would say when it comes to
that okay uh what about you I I see you
I see you nodding some so like I always
can kind of tell on the couch with the
nods well I think that he revolutionized
the internet yes yes who else went viral
like that nobody nobody but him and I
think the way he says think moves
feelings in like um younger people so
when someone speaks to them in a very
like harsh way they say oh let me maybe
it's true maybe I'm I'm not in the right
place where I should be maybe let's let
me change the narrative rather than okay
yeah well life is beautiful and you grow
up no go and get things done and I've
seen this like with my surrounding with
like younger people like really taking
action upon the words said upon things
like from going to the gym or like
learning a new skill I can see that he
has an impact like a positive one and
the thing is uh I don't know why people
like judge his videos on the outer
um part yeah Lamborghinis or like cars
or like girls but you look at the main
message of what he says he says get
better get money and be free don't Focus
about just about like uh The Superficial
things maybe it's an online persona it's
a marketing thing but the core of the
message is helping Humanity to be better
so there is no reason absolutely not no
reason to hit to hate undertake
okay what about you
um I'm very neutral in a situation I'm
not a fan but I don't dislike him
because obviously everyone has their own
opinions but he is oh can you hear me
now yeah he's he is very direct in what
he says and I think that's what people
have a problem with is how he says it's
like how he says it I don't think it's
pretty much what he says it's how it
comes across but again everyone has
their own opinion on things but for me
I'm just neutral on the situation like
obviously it's gone viral on YouTube
all platforms and I mainly see videos on
Tick Tock from what my sister shows me
but I don't really know so much about
him to judge him on his character so
that's why I'm saying I'm neutral on the
situation I actually have another
question
um for you so why do you think they're
looking so hard for um evidence against
him right now like why do you think
they're trying to lock him up
well the case is it's confusing
I mean he has he had a great impact on
people he has a lot of followers of
young people like the youth the next
working force of
that we're supposed to work for the
system so if he continues this way
things are gonna be not working the way
they used to so they have to stop this
impact somehow but
the case itself it's well I don't think
it's it's it's their I mean I have a lot
to say but
um well let me go through it first of
all yoga can accuse someone of
um a certain thing that must be
um
a bit degrading based on the um how can
I say this
um this the way the lifestyle you cannot
accuse someone of this with the
lifestyle he has the way he lives you
can just like find some other way
um like a credible crime to uh link it
to a person but in this case I don't
know
because are you saying because he has
some like he's so wealthy that it
doesn't seem like he would have an
incentive to do that because they're
they're accusing him of human
trafficking yeah yeah yeah why why would
he do this I think it doesn't make sense
do you um actually I'm gonna ask this
question later okay
um I'm gonna let everyone go what's you
guys's opinions Andrew Tate
my opinion on IGT
um big up to the top G is it
um what is the um I don't agree with
like all the things he says in it but
there are certain things that he says
just like do you agree with all the
things anyone says
me I have my you know I mean I have my
like own perspective on everything in it
like with Andrew T
his thing about like getting money and
all of that like man of knowing him
talking about getting money and being
like fit and healthy and all of that
stuff positive stuff in it the way he
talks about women
you know I mean not really like that but
most women would you not like that he
says about women
it's just like there's certain stuff
that he says and it's just a bit wild
like the whole the whole the whole thing
about um
if a woman's working for me or something
like that she has to give him
x amount of percentage and then she gets
like oh the only fans yeah the whole
only fans singing like I don't agree
with that and then do 50 50 if anything
like she should get half you should get
half but
most people you understand this point
though you know I get his point I get
his complete point I get his point but
it's not your body you're not the one
that's doing yeah I mean do it open
yourself putting yourself out there
you're just behind the screen you go I
mean most females hate him only because
of the little kids that's seen online
they don't sit down and watch the full
podcast or anything that's why most
people hate him because they don't
actually sit down and watch what he says
and listen to what he says yeah so
people have their own perspective on
everything but when you sit down and
listen to it says you're like all right
cool
maybe that I agree with that and then
but you've seen little Clips online and
all that even with this whole like
Instagram him getting Blackboard from
social media I don't agree with it
because
I don't agree with it I don't agree with
it and the reason why I don't agree with
him like getting the social medias and
getting blackboards because like
him getting Blackboard what's that got
to do with him being on podcast he don't
he don't mention anything about what
he's talking about or you don't push
anything on his platforms he just posted
his pictures and stuff like that
all the little Clips you're seeing of
him are from podcasts he's not putting
it on his social media so why decide why
do you decide to remove it from your
social media because he's opening people
like younger people's mind he's opening
everyone's Minds to The Matrix as he
would say the red pool the blue pill you
get so
I just with the whole only fans thing I
don't agree everything else I agree with
what he's doing this is the truth
what about you
I'm not a huge fan but like like Rush
said I agree with a lot of well a lot of
what he says
and I feel like he doesn't he doesn't
care what people think and that's the
best part a lot of kids our age
especially with cancel culture getting
too far nowadays everyone's caring about
what people think what's doing offending
someone but I think he's the first
person like a forerunner to actually
come out and say what he truly thinks
and like what rush said as well
have these things that are put on Tick
Tock and social media are clips from his
actual podcasts that aren't actually
being put out so I really feel like if
you're a young man trying to work trying
to get money he's trying to say okay get
get your bag get a house grow get
healthy don't worry about women now yes
some some of the things he says about
women are bad but when I was going
through Tick Tock and I see girls on
their Snapchat putting stuff like
all men are [__] or men aren't like they
used to stuff like that I don't see
anyone get mad at men or getting getting
mad at women when they're trashing men
I'm not saying all women are trashing
men but I think there's almost
on flip a script nowadays where it's
almost like men are the most hated thing
a straight man's the most hated thing in
the world and I feel like that's why
people hate Andrew Tate right now
because he's just speaking facts
sometimes let me show you another Point
as well yeah
women can survive without men
let me be real women could survive every
single man or should just disappear from
the Earth right now
they would survive and live on fine if a
man was to I don't I don't think
let me know
listen the reason why I say that is
because a woman can take a man's sperm
and kill every single man on the planet
and they could they could have babies
like that you get they can reproduce
like that us man we can't reproduce us
men are stupid
like no no no no no no no we're not
stupid in a sense and we're not stupid
in a sense like like we won't you know I
mean like a woman doesn't realistically
need a man I think women I think women
need men but men don't need women
because think about it if all the jaw
like men do all the jobs that run the
infrastructure of society exactly all of
them like the lighting the plumbing
building the buildings most of the
inventions were invented like you say
like you like I bet you IVF was created
by a
man's behind it that's the fingers
there's always a woman that's the brains
behind it how is it oh that's the Always
a Woman
I was gonna say most things are made by
man like not by women you know I'm
trying to say so I don't think the women
are the brains behind everything but
wasn't it a man that made a pad well
most things are made by man not by woman
yeah but I'm not talking about the most
I'm not talking about things that's made
by men physically we we're stronger
physically we're we're dominant you
think the world so yeah but mentally
like mentally if a woman wants to mess
up a guy they can do it bro you get like
let me show you another appointment I
think women are more manipulative than
men but that's different than saying
like that women have the brains in a
society I don't know because because men
invent the majority of things it's not
even about inventing I'm talking about
the process to the inventing that's what
she gets one yeah
the assembly lines are women
[Laughter]
I think that's a way for women to take
credit for men's accomplishments yeah I
think actually that's like female
narcissism because you know there's male
evil and there's female evil like you
know men can be evil in certain ways and
women can be evil in certain ways and I
think that the way women can be evil in
the world is pure narcissism
much more than men in my opinion and
yeah what they deserve and what they so
women know what they deserve on their
entitlement men doesn't so women use
that as a upper like a upper
um I thought a lot of females
feel are very entitled yeah yeah they
act very very easy that's entitled to
say that behind every man is like a good
woman
like because you're basically taking
Credit First yeah
most successful I grew up around
successful men they'll be successful
with or without a woman it's something
in them true like they're just the
hardest working first ones to work last
ones there like you know I love my dad
like he but he's he's really successful
but he would do that with or without my
mom
but I get his content she gets my
position no I think it's I think it's a
wrong Point
another thing as well another thing I
can see as well like a man could happily
go and exercise what we would call it
exercising we could happily go and sleep
with enough alone while loving another
woman
and not feel any type of infection for a
woman but a woman they get emotionally
attached so they can go and sleep with
another man
but if they sleep with that another guy
that's because you get that's because
they like they generally like that guy
you get you guys are emotionally
attached us man when we don't get
emotionally attached we just call it
exercise classes
no I agree with that
um do you guys disagree no I agree no I
agree
I'm more attached if they was to like
women get more attached in sex
he's basically saying so he's basically
saying it in a way as men can easily
super for women without feeling any
emotion as with women we have to feel a
type of way towards that person to give
up our bodies to them we ain't just
gonna go sleep with a guy just to sleep
with them obviously yeah
some women come about nine times out of
ten most women will sleep with a guy
that they have some type of feeling as
well because do you know what I mean
that's why it's looked up like like
that's why nowadays is looked upon as if
a woman if a woman has like motivated
multiple bodies you go I mean how does
that to your point though your original
point of saying that um if women were
only by themselves here like everyone
leader because realistically bro if I
call say all the women like teleport
from love right and it's just random how
do would we survive I mean how would we
how would we survive back industrial
actually listen just know just as men
they're building artificial wombs you'd
be surprised no like take away all of
that take away all of that if woman was
just describe from love how would Usman
survive okay
but women can't reproduce without men
no they can't they still need male sperm
exactly so you can take them no sperm no
but you said if the men weren't there
you can take you can take a most sperm
and you put this one
yeah but what okay what if they get to
the point where artificial wombs work
then you could take a female egg and do
the same thing which they're they're
making advancements basically I agree I
agree with that I agree with that but
but
I agree
um okay Andrew Tate what's your opinion
oh I like Andrew Tate as a personality
you know I'm saying um
I like to take everyone for themselves
but I decide what messages to take from
people in it so that Andrew Tate um
I think it's very direct
um tough love like I respect that I grew
up on that as well
um I just feel like a lot of people
don't like tough love and people being
direct because they wouldn't want to be
spoken to like that so that's why they
have that
um
because it's like why are you coming on
so hard like why are you speaking so
harshly but that's I'm telling you
straight up front so like it's rather
you're gonna take it or be upset by the
end of the day Andrew tells himself I
don't care this is this is what I'm
presenting to you so um as I said yeah
um I mess up Andrew taking it I like
watching them I like listening to him
but as I said um personally I would take
in the messages that I just I want to um
take on personally and apply to my
laptop that's how I see how do you take
it
no I was going to say in reality I feel
like most people were always judged on
how we look like for instance people may
judge you and say you're this and that
because of what you do like your job and
your podcast but you're actually a
really nice person so I think with
Andrew take naturally as humans we judge
as soon as we see someone like me
because I've got a resting [__] face
people automatically think I'm rude but
I'm like such a nice person like down to
earth and everything so I think it's
just like disaster
but I think as humans we not we
automatically judge people on like what
we see yeah but we don't that's it but
we don't give them that chance and I
think that's what people do with Andrew
take they're judging for what they've
before they've seen a lot yeah for what
they see and they're like oh he's this
and he's that when you really get to
know him and deep what he's saying
you're like right okay I agree so I
think it's all of that as well
yeah what what do you think
um
I'm not a massive follower I mean I
don't see kind of like his podcasts and
stuff I'm kind of like The Tick Tock and
the Instagram things about him
um I [__] with him you know I mean
he just he shakes it up you know
um it's like a man's man but
for me it's it's it's delivery and um
with his delivery some people take
offense to it and I guess if they know
him I don't know him but I guess if they
know him it would probably be a stand-up
kind of guy I don't know but um yeah
this the things that he says
um I agree I'm old school so like when
it comes to this say
um women with like loads of bodies and
got loads of
that's not a good look can I ask you a
question then go ahead all right cool so
there's something called a bush Beetle
so like basically beating around the
bush so would you rather someone beat
around the bush and tell you how you
should like handle a certain situation
and then leave a few to figure it out
will tell you up front and just tell you
the truth immediately
it's about being upfront straight up
this thing so then there's no point so
then if you say that then then wouldn't
Andrew Tate be you know what I'm saying
straight to the point but that's it
that's that's a that's a good thing I
mean a lot of people beat around the
bush and just they're not real it's
about being real nowadays but then a lot
of people don't like when people are
real because we take offense to it
because they're not real themselves
that's what I'm saying so it's about
whatever he says and anyone who can say
what you want is how you react to
certain things so if you're your mindset
is not
there if your mindset's not on level and
you know then you're going to take
advantage it's even he had a clip that
everyone was offended by where he said
um he preferred like 19 year olds to 26
year olds like he was like I'll tell you
why a 19 year old is hotter than a 26
year old she's got less bodies less
damage less this and I'm 20 36 and I
could have been offended but I was like
nah I could see that like I understand
where he's coming from they're younger
it's like duh you could say the same
thing about a 26 year old and a 50 year
old
no but she's just talking about
attraction well I mean I think in
America at least probably here like
women are overweight so most 19 year
olds are probably in better shape than
most 26 year olds
um 19 year olds you know have less exes
than 26 year olds and you know you could
you could do that with any age you could
do 25 and 35 but then like 19 triggers
people I don't know why
I wasn't that different at 19 versus 21.
like what's the difference I mean I
could see why people people get so
they're like I don't want to say
anything I don't wanna physically
obviously he's gonna like the 19 year
olds instead of the 26 but I think
mentally I don't know about most 19 year
old girls they're probably not
there yet as in for an older guy who has
everything has the money why is he why
would he go for a girl that's maybe
still a girl you know I mean maybe needs
to be a bit more
I don't know woke in a sense I think
like on to your point I feel like
with him it's more when you're 26 you're
like four years till 30 you're looking
to settle down
buy a house have some kids have a dog
have a garden all of that yeah when
you're 19 you're you're yeah
summer outside you get you're living
your life you're living your best life
all of that I think that's why and
because he's obviously a guy he's a guy
that you know I mean he's not a settle
down guy he's sick that's why he's
probably saying that because he's like
oh these girls they're not ready to grow
up and mature and yeah no I think he
says it in the clip it's because they're
younger
um and you know they have less damage
yeah that's true the older you are the
more the older you are as a woman the
more damaged you are true
oh no that uni phase is scary yeah the
university
a 19 year old girl that did not go to
UNI probably start the nine to five and
everything is more mature than a girl
that actually has gone to Union I
obviously there's going to be
differences between girls but by and
large like a girl that's 19 is gonna
have slept with less people than a girl
that's 29.
this generation nowadays is really scary
very
older women say that to compete with
younger women
how much odor
all older in general yeah I think they
say that like to remarket themselves no
I really do because then they can tell
my generation's better than their
generation we have less bodies but no I
think in general like if you have less
like if you're younger you have less
experience
the kids nowadays are more exposed to a
lot of things
I think it depends where you're from
when like your environment you know well
which is why I say in general right yeah
yeah even if we just take the same girl
at 29 versus 19 she's had more
experience at 29. yeah you know I was in
a train once I was having a conversation
with a couple of um a female a couple of
my females a month gospel choir and like
someone overheard me I was a younger
girl and she was we're going to the
conversation about bodies or how many
men you slept with and she's like it's
not a problem you know why are you
making it such a big thing you know most
guys they like that type of stuff I was
like wow is that where yes your mindset
is going you wait till
10 years time then
the guy would not appreciate that it's I
don't know it's just the younger
generation nowadays it's like
I don't know what they think they're
about them free I've had younger guys
try and chat with me shout out to them
it doesn't really matter the age on both
like whether you're male or female
you think the old ladies is a higher
body count
like more important not important as in
as into a bag of bag of guys someone
that I mean you know I have another
relationship I mean as in like well if a
girl's oh if she's got more bodies then
like the guy that she's speaking with
foreign
if you want like a like let's say
literally homebody but like homebodies
can actually okay exactly
if I'm talking to a girl I'm dating a
girl she can have mini buddies bodies
that she wants but once I get my wife I
don't want my wife the bearer of my
children to have 28 bodies bro but then
I'm gonna be I'm gonna start thinking
about who knows what yeah
that that's just me personally bro no I
hate it
a girl that's got so many bodies but
your wife is the one that you're cuffing
it doesn't matter because you've
literally already had the girl that's
been in but I'm not I'm not having kids
with that girl without Harley he's just
trying to choke
and that's the problem and that's the
problem girls thinking oh man doesn't
it's not a big deal where they're not
bothered because they just want to slam
and that's the point if it's someone who
wants a proper relationship that usually
mindset they're a bit older and they
want to settle down so they're not going
to go They're not going to go for
somewhere you're gonna have to go to
somewhere like back back in Africa a
bone through her nose just to have
someone a female that hasn't got
nobody's account you know what I mean I
don't know what you're gonna get that
nowadays are you you can't there's some
more things out there
what age group would you say that I'm
talking about
I was like as a guy it has to be tough
because there's really no way you can
get a good woman in a way because social
media will always affect women and so
like I've been doing this divorce
documentary right and I've been
interviewing like guys and they like
there's one guy he had one fight with a
girl in seven years she came from a
traditional Muslim household what what
more could you want like one fight
doesn't that sound good traditional
background she was young when they got
married and she screwed this man over
took his kids because she got um
involved like it was either social media
or she got around some single like
divorced friends and they kind of
influenced her and then she switched
because women are more susceptible to
propaganda than men so like that's how
politicians like control elections and
that's how advertisers like Market
mostly to women and so I was like it's
gonna be tough as a guy because even if
you get a girl with like the perfect
back ground like social media can still
kind of brainwash women in a way
so I mean I have a point I okay I'm 44
and I have been divorced um I'm in like
a
just under three-year relationship with
with someone and uh
she's older and um
I'm hoping it's true she hasn't got that
much bodies but you never know but from
what I've spoken to her she's the real
deal and like you usually at a girl in
her in her 40s they would have to go for
someone older they can't go anyone
younger just
they're not mentally there yet or
they've I don't know but
my point is that um
I'm in a good relationship and when it
comes to
um
body count I'm sorry it's a big [__]
sight
it's a big deal and just knowing some of
the things that she said it still bugs
me but
that's that's that's me trying to
get over myself
um as a reflection of that so I trust
that we trust each other right she's
older and she's had that problem because
again younger guys would approach her
and um but they're just about
messing around and stuff so she wasn't
ready for that she doesn't want that she
just wants a serious relationship and
funny enough I came along and just
happened to be all right she got her
king that's right how was um how was the
divorce process for you was it so my my
divorce happened during pandemic and if
you see in your stats uh majority is
either two ways it went more babies or
more divorces oh it's true during
pandemic it's just it's like it's like
an eye-opener when you're an epidemic
anyway
um so that happened and it was it was
tough it was it was tough
the only way we so we've got a daughter
and when it comes to uh our daughter we
think on the same wave room but when it
comes to us it was never meant to be so
um
we just she filed for divorce because if
you're on benefits it's you have to pay
as much and but I did the whole
solicitor thing and we had to agree in a
lot of stuff I know people that if you
don't agree on it that's where the
process gets more take care yeah so so
it wasn't so bad for you no I I'm I
don't know man I'm blessed I got like an
angel on my shoulder from life I'm just
I don't know so that situation went okay
even though
I I don't even know she's probably worse
I don't even want to say
it's it's weird it's with her and
probably with a lot of
Australian tables but females uh it goes
back to you know
daddy issues
no speakers
and so if it's like that princess
mentality you feel that you you're old
and you don't want to work for things
and and you know the the Father Figure
looks out for you and does all that
stuff so that's kind of where she saw me
in that situation where I thought that
when I first came into the relationship
um it was good but
um
maybe about maybe two months into it she
fell pregnant and that's kind of for me
I did what my upbringing was was to be
the better man and steak stick with it
but I saw so many red flags it was crazy
it's bad just just I just stuck at it
and
she's always at those red flags and she
doesn't think that she does
so everyone know this is the problem not
her it took a long while man we went
through therapy and stuff and
it's just I think she still doesn't get
it still doesn't get it it's maybe a
young mentality young a childlike
mentality
she's probably watching but to a point
that where I have boyfriend now
is someone who's a who is a boy who
still lives at home with his mum she's
almost in her 40s oh wow right I'm Dame
I'm dating the woman that's got her [__]
together I got my [__] together we're
working together
you know we're making it work you can't
well thank you well that's the thing I
it was a bad situation
it flipped I'm I'm in the happiest place
I am and I'm here I'm here on this show
I'm here with you I'm happy to be here
and stuff so but yeah divorce it sounds
like you got out easy relatively yeah I
am actually speaking to another friend
of mine who's going through pretty bad
situation with his
soon to be ex-wife obviously they're
separated but again he's telling me the
same things that I'm hearing like even
though they were separated
just to he wanted her she didn't want
him he's like or if you're not being
serious I just I don't want to be even
in the same bed of you I'm going to
sleep on a couch I'm like oh my God I
went through [__] like that that's nuts
and child mentality she always thinks
everywhere everybody else is wrong not
him oh no not her and I was like I've
been there I've been through all that
why do you think um feminism has
convinced women that they'll be better
on the other side of divorce especially
after children
so they could
so they can back some money so they can
they can have I guess
some of the power that the main the man
may have had beforehand oh so they can
get money out of it oh big time but you
know child support yeah what's the
consequence if you leave if you can just
put them on child support
exactly that's that's what raised your
hand did you have something to say
um
I forgot what I was gonna say now okay
no worries if not but
um no it's just the whole divorce and
separation it's just the whole um
actually I had a question for you
because you said you had so many red
flags but he's still continued what made
you for the sake of my daughter
but beforehand because the reason why
I'm asking you because when I got
married
um I saw red flags as well myself but I
chose not to I chose to avoid it so I
just wanted to know
um you saw the red flags but what made
you still go ahead because I saw the red
flags before getting married but the
fact that I was pregnant as well it was
the thought of doing the right thing but
then you've ended up continuing but
going back to the beginning where you
could have avoided so many it's true
it's kind of like
that time travel thing if would I go
back in time and change things or would
I still have my daughter now I wouldn't
change the world I wouldn't change a
thing for my dad for my daughter so I
did in my in my family my mom and dad
got divorced and separated my dad
cheating I just knew I didn't want to go
down that route of what he did so I I
was the better man and I stuck at it yes
I saw red flags but I knew my daughter's
in the picture so I just I just carried
on but we weren't married but we were
together but it's I even went that
further down the line Maybe
I don't know six years down the line
then we got married and it still went
wrong so I put everything on the table
for her to try and make it work and it
still didn't work so that's why when
pandemic came I was like okay
this is the real deal I can't I can't do
this anymore I'm out I'm out but if
you're to answer your question it's
solely for my daughter
simple blood
I think men are much more willing to
stick it out for the kids than women are
typically they are I agree which which
is weird because you would think like
women like it's always the narrative
that women are like closer to the kids
so it's weird that like men seem to
stick it out more
yeah go ahead I think um men always have
the the nature to love for their
children I think every man loved their
children regardless however us female
can um I don't know if it's
intentionally or not what can make a man
no matter how much they feel or love
their children they can make them not
want to be around or exist and I think
that's where the problem is not whether
the man loves their child or whatever
because every man that I've spoken to
because I've got a lot of male friends
who's got children and has experienced
something similar to him and as a woman
who's experienced the same thing but I'm
a woman so it's like I have more support
they don't men don't have
men don't have that
this way men don't have that support
they're just seen as the bad person oh
where's he gone oh he's not doing
nothing he's not doing that but they
never focus on okay why isn't he doing
anything because I believe that there's
no man who's given birth to a child on
Earth that doesn't love their children
that's that's just how I feel but it's
just harder for them to they're not
supported to deal with their emotions or
regulate their emotions so sometimes
when they're trying to communicate or
Express their feelings
there seem as being angry or being
aggressive
so for them they feel the best thing for
them to do is not be around which I feel
is very sad but yeah
what do you think teeth
about it um
yeah um I think he's a he's a funny
character
um he's very motivational for me
personally
um I like watching his videos he speaks
a lot of Truth
um in the internet right now you it's
really hard to find truth and people
being real
um I also think he's like a marketing
genius I think he's really smart making
money and you know uh I like learning
from the things he's done to make money
um he's got a good mindset I like his
mindset um the belief mindset you know
if you believe you can do this you can
do this
um if you believe you are sick then you
are sick you know um
um yeah I think it's very motivational
and he's like you know he's helped me
out a lot personally
um and he says a lot of real things yeah
how has he helped you
personally
um so like just motivation really man
like sometimes you know I'm just like
you know editing or doing something on
my computer and then I'm just like on
YouTube or something then I see one of
his videos and I click on it
and he's like yo man you gotta do this
man life is a competition it's PVP
player versus player you know and I'm
not thinking to myself bro like life is
really player versus player you know I'm
trying to say like you're in competition
with everybody else you know I mean in
anything you do and um you know kind of
one makes me want to like you know work
harder and stuff so yeah
it doesn't always have to be PPP I do
believe that yes everyone is competing
but for example I met this guy like four
months ago and we've been growing
together not on some weird [__] but like
as like content creators like people if
you have that mindset you're gonna
always come through life always paranoid
or always thinking people you meet are
always I mean not not necessarily but
I'm saying
it's always good to have a positive
perspective not all the time but like
it's better to grow with people than
think of everyone's an enemy thinking
okay discussion negative yeah I was
about to say that yeah like you you
can't you competed in football
basketball I don't think it's necessary
what am I competing about is I get
pissed off I can't compete happily like
in sports I'm not like oh I'm gonna beat
you right now like no I'm trying to beat
you bro like if I want to win I want to
win I I guess you can compare you go
hard and then you still shake hands
after but not not happily not not
because
that's why I don't want to see I want to
see as this as a competition I just want
to see it as like okay everyone can grow
if they want to have it and not see
everyone as like a PVP I like seeing
everybody win do you not gain motivation
off your of your friend's success
so if you're like let's say you're
supporting your boy I'm I'm assuming
that whoever is whoever is within your
circle
you're supporting whatever Grand they're
doing you know what I'm saying whether
it's music content creating you're going
up to their shows you're turning up for
their videos and stuff like that and you
know what I'm saying like you're seeing
progression yeah yeah obviously they're
still supporting you and you're doing
your own thing yeah but it motivates me
it doesn't it doesn't make me I'm not
looking at rush like oh this man got
100K views last night I gotta get 200.
now but doesn't that push me like right
if he can I can do that too yeah
but maybe it's perspective maybe it's
perspective maybe it's perspective but
in the same way it kind of still is PVP
you know what I'm saying okay I don't
know if you know about Kaya sinat Duke
Dennis
um Aiden Ross see all of them had their
own time there was a point where Duke
Dennis was on top of the church and I'm
saying what kind Aiden are still there
you know I'm saying there's a thing
where Aiden was now on top yeah okay
but all these men are still there do you
understand so it's still PVP because at
the end of the day only one person could
be number one at one time yeah but
you're still at the end of the day
you're always gonna look at the number
one it's always gonna be motivated by
the number one so you're still competing
for the followers so you're still going
to number one in our generation right
now then in terms of let's say this
content is talking about social content
let's talk about Source like following
is
[Music]
I think he's funny but I don't know like
he they took him off of everything he
was still everything yeah exactly
exactly so I mean as I said perspective
in it yeah I feel like PVP it can be
taken positively it can be taken
negative no no no no no I think I think
life is PVP whether you want to accept
it or not man anything man like how much
money you make the house you're staying
in
um what you can afford
um where you go even even in content
like generally man like everything is
ranked everything's all in an algorithm
ranked whether you like it or not you're
not going to be in the same level as
your friend it's not going to happen and
one of you is always going to do better
and that's just life but people don't
like the acceptance like survival of the
fittest that's just what life is but I
feel like a lot of people don't like to
accept it you know obviously I like to
see people grow I like see you know I
like to help people and stuff like that
and everyone everyone wants that you
know I'm gonna say but in reality it's
PVP man whoever works the hardest gets
gets to the place you know what I'm
trying to say
um and yeah maybe it's based off um
intent you know what I'm saying I think
it's intense
yeah so if your intention is like it's
based off jealousy that's why you're
gonna beat him yeah that's when you know
I'm saying that's negative energy you're
producing that's evil eye do you
understand what's the thing where I want
to be up there with my bro you know what
I'm saying
you don't want to be the best yeah you
want to be the best
I'm just I'm just curious something I
just thought about do you guys any of
you have YouTube channels
um yeah you have one yeah um how many
Subs do you have roughly
for like a year now okay it's definitely
less than like 200. okay I was just
thinking about like female versus male
privilege in the room because it's like
girls just have to live
yeah
I don't even know if they have like
channels or not but I was like yeah I
don't know you just said 100 million or
I don't know 2 million views something
like that yeah whatever it was then he's
like got this whole love Island yeah
I was just thinking about the male
versus female privilege yeah what
well statement you said yeah that if men
and women were separated you think the
women would survive of course you think
so yeah so if the man them were on one
Island and the woman won another Island
yeah you'd go on the women's Island to
survive
no no I never said that I said I said
like realistically men can't survive
without a woman
that's just the truth women can survive
without men that's what I said wait so
so you're trying to say that these
ladies here you go in there to taste
and under their constructions and I'm
just saying like how would you separate
like what do you mean
your point your point there I'll give
you I'll give you your point in it my
point is realistically if a woman wants
if a woman was was to take like a man's
sperm to reproduce and make their own
thing and carry on or whatever because
they women are alive bro yeah we're
making carry life bro man can't do that
so you're saying they can carry life but
that's why I said they have the upper
hand we don't so it was the first so we
have to work wait we have to work it was
the first human a man or woman
it was a man okay so man can survive
over a woman nobody yeah
was necessary
the man so when she had the when she has
the baby she was she she gonna have a
man or a woman or is it random it
depends she can have both she can have
any right so let's add the childbirth
and pearl said there is ways that you
could have yes wombs that are artificial
yeah so we could we could make kids
without it but that's made by humans bro
I'm talking about like nature I'm
talking about nature sounds IVF that's
not natural
human involved all right Let's do let's
do it by a show of hands ladies which
one of you could change the title
[Laughter]
which one of you that could cook
Amanda which one of you could clean
you see what I'm saying so when it comes
to women's responsibilities men know how
to do it we've been taught how to do
women's responsibilities as well
can you light a fire yeah or purified
water yeah well if I give you an island
I cannot fire for wood I can I can like
I can light a fire from woods with a
lighter no like no Robin what's it like
that old school yeah
it's about facts it's about men run all
of the industries that make Society run
that's true all of them being pushed the
fact is
necessary
but who's behind you but who's behind me
he's behind him
because men men run wait wait men run
makes a
[Music]
side well he's behind the man what's
that who's behind what is the female
there's a movie that um
you're saying the woman the woman
sitting at home cooking yeah and
cleaning that that's behind the man yes
wait wait and that and that has enough
impact that they could that that man
can't survive without woman even though
every man in this room said he can cook
for himself but how we taught him wait
wait
let me ask you a question
that doesn't make Society run what do
you mean okay okay even Let's Take
cooking right to the Bare Bones who
[Music]
Farms
can but don't but don't they choose not
to no because men's been taught from the
dawn of time to look afterwards
you feel like what she's saying yeah but
like you've seen it from a different
yeah a queen yeah she's saying the
initial the initial and the original
people that are doing this other man
regardless if even if
even if men can't even put salt and
pepper into rest a man can still survive
and still produce a brick wall I think
that's what she's trying to say what
you're trying to do is talk about the
support man can still play football
without football boots
do you get you're talking about the
football boots yeah you know what I'm
saying even though I will perform better
old football boots
okay I still have feet to kick again do
you get what I'm saying so like I think
it's two different Queens I feel like
you're thinking they are the backbone
but we can still stand do you get what
I'm saying so you know what I'm saying
in other ways we need it well we kind of
both need each other yeah
[Music]
this is this feminist egalitarian
[__] we've been programmed too
women need Madness equally as men need
women you you just can't equally but
that's what I'm saying when we say we
need each other like women need men men
do not need women
because men can survive without women
women cannot survive without men they
didn't think they tested this I'll tell
you they tested this in this reality
show right they took the medicine they
took the women and they put them on two
separates
oh that's the real thing yeah that was
the real thing the camera crew had to
rescue the women in like two or three
days older women yeah and all the men
had the whole system running they'd like
giving each other jobs when the women
were just arguing about who had to do
what yeah so true you're so true okay
and the only reason that women like we
think we can survive without men
nowadays is because men have built
systems that help us survive yeah so
like a single woman like what is she
gonna do when someone breaks into her
house normally you'd have a man but if
you don't have a man who do you call the
police I swear I'll hit him or beat him
up
okay no I will I'm hurting him up and I
look after my children how are you gonna
beat up any of these I'm six foot five
men like he he comes bro I'm sorry
we're live there's different things that
I can make you disable your strength
okay and also why does it have to be a
six foot man
even an average guy can beat you up even
an average guy like okay guys even let's
just take sports right let's just take
Sports and that's at the lowest level
okay that's at the lowest level I've had
16 years of training in basketball 16
years average guys beat me all the time
yeah that didn't even have training like
that that don't lift like that
but I mean when it comes to sports
no when you beat someone up it's way
more significant like it's more
significant than Sports I'm just saying
at the lowest level Sports you're not
doing [__] of someone like why is
feminine feminism in the media deluded
women into thinking you can have
actually beat up a dude
it doesn't matter what you think you
would do you know I'll let you wrestle
any of these guys on the show I'll I'll
pay you a thousand dollars if they can't
[Laughter]
I swear to God
like it doesn't matter how much you feel
you can beat him up you can't these are
physical facts like
just women cannot be men I mean that's
that's tell them Science Biology yeah
it's not something to be argued but then
that's it women would think they can and
they would give it all the gold up into
a man's face until a man switches on it
then they get a woman just keeps quiet
and just goes to the corner because he
comes out he comes real but if you talk
about you know Christian rock and blue
face oh my God
knows the situation blueface can't act
crazy have you seen what
Christian does to that guy
she is that that girl is messed up that
guy's crib if any guy wasn't I can't lie
I actually give it to blueface because
that guy has a patience patience yeah
if he was if it was the wrong guy yeah
and it would be crazy
it would be crazy so you have to give it
to blueface he said this on kick game as
well like
um I think it came out like a few days
ago like there was a YouTube video on
the kick game channel where he was
featured on and the guy that the
interview was asking him about like him
and blue like um him and um's
relationship and how how does he deal
with that how does he do that and he's
just like like man like just let her go
like she's a woman just like just let
her go off and all of that stuff so I
feel like it's just pushed aside he just
pushes it aside and he doesn't care but
he he was saying also like he he said
good point he said like because he's in
the relationship he understands the
relationship everybody's looking from
the outside is seeing a whole different
thing from what's going on actually
inside so only they them to understand
the relationship no one else actually
understands the relationship you get
it's the same with the Andrew Tate thing
you don't understand like you don't
understand what he's actually saying or
what he's experienced because all you
just see is a two second clip on Tick
Tock all you see on Instagram reels but
you're not actually seeing the phone
yeah
that's that full interview on no jumper
where she got kicked out
that's it exactly yeah but I think the
point is even if he really tried he
could beat the [__] out of her yeah if
he wanted to yeah why would he put hands
on them
she's beating him up but what do they
call her do you see what I mean yeah
it's about this is one thing that annoys
me like
a lot of double standards men do
something they get name they get
coordinates but if us as a woman do the
same thing nothing gets said about it
it's okay but then so why is it not okay
for man does it Johnny Depp and Amber
in reality everyone knows like a woman
is weaker than a man even though we
can't speak about it and say it like
that but like in reality that's why
people don't really care like in general
it's like when a girl hits a guy people
don't say anything but when a guy hits a
girl people say women yeah we know it's
wrong it's right but yeah it's written
into the law that like the the weaker
perpetrator which is always the woman is
like automatically the victim
wow
that's why you see those like when like
guys will call the DV on their
girlfriends and they arrest the guy
that's why there's I I don't know the
ins and outs of it but I know I didn't
know some men that get domestic
but it's not spoken about well it's
really easy for women oh yeah like oh
because that was I was actually gonna
ask if anyone in the room like knows a
guy that's been falsely accused of a
crime yeah
oh yeah just to raise his hands I'm just
curious
wow wow that's great so what
so seven out of nine
what I mean like falsely accused of
grapes like yeah like I'm talking about
yeah so I went to college in the US a
small D2 school called OVU my first
college and a bunch of Colombian guys
went out did their thing it was three
American girls and three Colombian guys
things happened that night they were
embarrassed and kind of ashamed of it it
went on for like a couple months and at
the end
they were accused of eating grapes and
then once it happened they got deported
back to Colombia lost their scholarship
lost everything and it came and it came
out one of the girls snitched and said
that she it was all false and nothing
happened to him after wow and yet they
still stayed in Colombia didn't get a
chance for Education lost her
scholarship everything
and it happens all you'll be surprised
happens all the time my boy managed to
get a like get it settled when it
happened because like good armor man it
was my first this is my first year in
America
um at least three weeks in and um
he had a two-month step so it was
um him and another guy and um
Yeah so basically they went back to the
crib
you know you know the the build up stage
in it the movies and that and the green
light so they both went to their
different rooms and um cool one of my
boys gets police coming to his door a
few hours later
two pack and then boom um oh yeah we're
here to um talk to you about a potential
did you get and um cool so he gave him
the little
um
breakdown of how the night went
so I called him anyway the next morning
like yo what happened what happened he
was like oh yeah
um
nothing escalated I asked for consent
and I feel like she felt a type of way I
don't know why but anyway she left next
thing I know I'm getting police at my
door now I have to get a statement
so now he has to go back to coach to get
us um a statement from coaches he has to
go to teachers in the school to get a
statement statement from other players
and stuff like that unfortunately
unfortunately he stayed and all the
allegations got um dropped but three
weeks just to start your uni wow and
that's already happened bro yeah
exactly so I'm in America and I'm I saw
that live oh I saw that live oh wow to
me that was a massive it deterred you
didn't it deterred you for sure like my
father to tell me like go on like going
to cause like look do not do anything
I'm talking about like if they kiss you
like there's so many times where I went
to a girl's place and I had done nothing
just in case like me and her or times
where I literally recorded being like
okay sorry to be such a weirdo but do I
have consent to do this because me being
a 604 605 black guy if I do this and she
says yes then she turns around and goes
actually you know what I didn't like it
I'ma say he bought grips the Judgment
believe me or her the five foot five
girl but on the flip side though do you
all think that women could sell grapes
to men
is that possible do y'all believe that
yeah I've heard that you know
it's possible but I think I think
vulnerability I heard of a girl like
drugging a guy and then thinks she would
like she would drug guys and do stuff to
them
major at the time I've heard it as the
goal was older than the guy so
statutory yeah I'm saying like you're
you're a young boy you're not saying
goofy PVE and that you're feeling all
type of ways and uh he's coming on to
you you don't even know how to act
you're just going with the flow but
really and truly you have no idea what's
going on then bow
you know what I'm saying you've done the
thing because something like that
happened over here but it was on the
news where a teacher had um a racist
relationship with a younger student in
her school and they classed that as
great because obviously he was younger
and she was a lot older and I think she
yeah
she did because she felt pregnant for
him yeah
do you ever notice how we always take
accountability off of women Even in our
like language because I always hear men
or men and women use the term I'm not
picking on you but I just like fell
pregnant like it sounds like it just
like happened yes you know what I mean
yeah if they're even like he knocked her
up that so that implies that he did it
not her yeah
obviously I don't mean it like that but
it's just how I speak no I know
subconscious yeah subconscious it's
right what you've said yeah it's so
normalizing I didn't actually think
about it like that but it's even like it
here it's so common for you guys use
partner
do you want to be in a partner like an
equal partnership is that what you guys
want you don't want a husband or a wife
you have a partner I want to laugh still
yeah
because like partner implies that we're
equal and I don't think women are equal
to men I think men are superior to women
especially in relationships because
women date up
um
like do you want a guy that's Broker
Than You dumber than you and fatter than
you no I'm not someone who's gonna
Elevate and grow with me actually
I feel like it depends on the individual
what does that mean all right not you
sorry Elevate and grow what women say
this and I don't even know what it means
like so like what do you want to build a
man
he's on his journey I'm on my journey
where we can help each other we can but
he's not I don't owe him and he don't
own me but we are growing together and
that also means that they might get to a
paper what does that look like like
because sometimes you say this stuff
like yeah like grow with me like we're
both pursuing careers together we're
both like what is it because like in
marriage aren't you supposed to grow
together like it's two become one yeah
but it's not always like that all the
time because of feminism and like modern
mentality but not like how it's supposed
to be like what's worked the last
Thousand Years
like I think this is what we've like
kind of brainwashed women that like
we're equal and but we're not could I
give a potential example to that yeah so
let's say um oh sorry are you straight
um let's say potentially uh the woman
she is uh she wants to be a director the
film director and then the man was to be
an actor so basically both these two
people are driven by both their
aspirations and dreams so that's that's
their Common Ground that's their common
that's their common Bond and it's not
necessarily too tough about their living
situation how many holidays they go they
go on because that's not what brings
them happiness in it it's more or less
of the journey that they're going to go
for so the guy is doing his acting thing
oh yeah meets this person networks oh
babe I met this guy I'm able to help you
out bow bow boom now she's on the next
thing she might get a higher role Marvel
ah babe just got into this Marvel room
I mean yeah I feel like some people
I mean I can't give you something
specific no I mean if this is a common
thing I just want to know like that just
like something it's not coming sometimes
I feel like like women when we say
things it just sounds like like La La
Land like even you said this one but you
know but it's like what percent of
couples are film directors and actresses
and at the end of the day I think this
is like the problem in society is like
our goal is a career instead of a family
like because you can't do everything but
I really can't someone's got to give up
their [__] if you have kids
exactly and who is it going to be who's
better with kids
the woman who should be home with the
children you know so that's why I just
don't understand when it's like this
equal like we're gonna grow together
like it just sounds like that's part of
the journey as well because when it when
like you said when it comes to building
a family that's a journey that we're
doing individually and together because
being a parent it changes you as well so
that's enough for Journey that my
whoever who I'm with may not have met at
the beginning because that's a different
when you enter being a parent that's
like a different part that you're
experiencing as well so when I'm talking
about Journey not necessarily career
aspects just in someone that you connect
with because it doesn't you're not going
to work for someone that you don't
understand or willing to understand or
have a connection is is not gonna
it's not going to work that's that's how
I see it what does that mean could you
elaborate like if it's not going to work
if you don't have a connection if you
don't if you're not happy with yourself
number one it's no relationship is going
to work really I think that
relationships used to work all the time
when people weren't happy with
themselves like you know when there was
a relationship or were they hiding
behind skeletons no I don't think they
were hiding behind skeletons I think
that life gets hard and I think that
people used to stick it out when life
got hard and now like women care about
their happiness more than their own
family because yeah because because in
the old days your husband was in War
what problems do we have in 2023 like
what are we arguing about nothing yeah
it's like like people used to go to war
there used to be famines there used to
be there you know there used to be
depressions whatever we're in the
greatest most modern time in human
history
like what what are we fighting about
in a relationship are you ready to
Mother even your husband
in a way
yeah I mean when you said
um yeah we're growing together yeah it's
good but you have to have a base at
least to start from you're not there to
even like invest in like mothering your
husband you have to have a man that
takes care of you so you have a family
so you can go together in a certain
route
not you being in charge of this man oh
when I'm saying growing together is not
in Chuck because I don't want to be a
mother to anyone that's not everyone's
child like but it sounds like when you
say that it sounds like you're dictating
the direction of the relationship I
don't know if that's what you mean but
that's how it sounds okay maybe I'm not
explaining it properly like for example
with with my marriage it came to a point
where
he felt it was best because he he didn't
he wasn't responsible enough to he still
wanted to live the life that he wanted
to because when he when you mean the
life he wanted to he wants to be free
like he he's not ready like what is free
and is that like other women going out
like what does free mean well do you
know what I can't answer for him because
I'm not him but this is based on what
he's said to me he's still on his
journey so as a as as a wife how how
how do I
how do I explain how do I explain that
how do you receive that as a wife if
your husband has turned around and said
that he wants to
continue I'd find himself that's the
word find himself what what do you do
but he's already made the commitment
so you guys are married yeah you're
married for how long
so let's say three years three four
years three four years you've got a
child okay so you have a child and then
he he sits you down one day and says
what
that he needs to work on himself so he's
gone through things growing up okay
and he's now realized that he needs to
work on them because if he doesn't it
will it's going to implicate
us being together because he hasn't
worked on himself okay so what does he
want to do he wants to go to therapy he
wants to so that's the part he did
didn't know what he wanted to do but he
didn't want it to affect me or our
daughter so he felt the best thing for
him to do
was to separate which to me
I didn't think that was the best thing
because as a family we're meant to grow
things together and see how things what
does that mean to you guys if a guy says
yeah like what a guy's point of view
what does that mean
I mean I want to give I want to give I
like I like to give the manifested adult
you know because obviously as I said
I don't know what's going through
Sacramento's head but I know as a guy as
I run I've heard everybody come back
here you understand that when we go
through whatever we're not even
necessarily relationships but we like to
keep it to ourselves even if we're in
our own crib with our March and our dad
and our sister no matter what we're
going through we do not like it to
affect what is going on in the household
so if that was if that is what was going
through
um my brother's head at the time then
fair enough he doesn't want to bring his
personal problems and admit it and let
the energy affect the family so what
happens to two becomes one do you do you
feel like you were his peace in the
relationship
that's a deep
breath
only he could only he could answer that
because that's what I wanted to know
because he said it it had nothing to do
with me or anything
but he thought that he was too damaged
that he didn't want it to affect it it's
just it's so weird because the way he's
talking is very like feminine do you
ever say that sounds like a very like
feminine way yes it was like okay I'm
too like you know that that's like
against me which is something that I'm
not used to it because I'm not used to
yeah um that's that's the first time so
yeah it is very feminine but can I say
something
yeah go ahead
I think that don't you think that
because you've have allowed since uh the
first time that you are like equality or
like being both equal that he took the
feminine side and leaves you with the
masculine side of taking control
that's it but what I did was when I did
get married
um I I stepped back and let him lead
because especially my mom she's Nigerian
so from
as that culture you let the man leave
even though growing up I didn't believe
that because of certain things that I
went through growing up but when I got
married and obviously as a mother I want
to do right and make sure I'm a good
role model to my daughter so when it
came to the whole African culture of
letting a man lead you share respect or
whatever that was all me that's why I
really wanted to understand what was
wrong when he was ready to separate and
he had to let me know like babe it's not
you I've gone through some stuff grown
up and this is where I'm at right now
it's hard I can't be mad at him because
every other woman would be like oh you
can't go this and that whatever but I I
just said you know what all right cool
he said why didn't why are you angry
white in class because you've said to me
that you need help and you want to focus
on yourself I can't be mad at you I have
a question I have a question
um do you
okay um my question goes like this so
did you
did you used to let him lead
or was he a leader
he wasn't a leader yeah I identified
that but I still let him lead because
with with I did I didn't know because
I'm not used to I'm so used to having my
own
so when I met a man that didn't know how
to lead I still allowed untrusted him
too late
and when I saw that he wasn't needing I
just prayed to God to guide me was you
more dominant the reason why I asked
that is because when you when you say
you let a man lead he from your
perspective it might come it might come
Acro my come across like that the way
you're looking at it but in reality if
someone else was looking at it from a
third person point of view it would
usually look like
and I don't want I'm not trying to I
don't know be free but we usually look
like
um you're it's almost like it will
always almost come of condescending in a
way because
you might think you're letting him lead
but even some of the ways you will react
to the things he would do would always
come off like oh well
and Men pick up on stuff like that so if
if if that's the way your relationship
is going it's most of the time would
lead to the same eventual what he said
is very important and because I had a
lot of brothers growing up so all of
these little things because they spoke
about how females behave and stuff so I
was very aware of everything and how to
the point where I found myself having to
control my behavior just because I was
conscious of not letting him feel less
of a man because I knew that there was
something wrong however I didn't know
what was wrong so I just ended up
praying to God instead to teach me and
guide me and then that's when he was
able to comfortably come to me and say
listen this is what's going on and I
just took it as a sign of God has
answered my prayer because now I
understand what I'm in and it's just
which way to go because then it's just
like I don't really want to be a single
mother but it's just how you look at it
because I don't see it as I'm a single
mom because he still exists he's not
dead he's we're just not together but my
daughter how long have you been
separated
um
it's coming up to four years oh why
you've been separated that long yeah
it's coming up to four years and yeah
I just let him go and we it's so funny
because when we speak he would never
tell that we
are separated because he still has that
respect for me obviously when he gets
out of line we still have our little ups
and downs but
he we both have an understanding of
where we are at in life and he's on his
journey and I'm on his journey I'm not
worrying about what he's doing who he's
with whatever and vice versa obviously
it still hiccups when it comes to our
daughter but I don't curse him or
anything I just let him
grow and when he's ready to do what he
needs to do
yeah that sounds hella similar to that
my parents relationship growing up like
I didn't even notice that they were even
together that's how close me and my dad
and my mom was at the same time because
my dad
was always there like he was there and
he wasn't together but they were he was
there to get it so wherever me and my
siblings needed we would always have it
we would never need like you know I mean
until we got to a point where obviously
you have to go Jamaican but growing up
like from it from like birth growing up
my parents both been in my life so it's
just like all right cool
yeah I mean most people don't get that
and that's that's the most important
thing that's what I feel that's what's
important the parents been in the lives
even though they're not together because
that's where we kind of get confused
like oh because we're not together then
it's just like oh we have to do a lot of
arrangements this that no because we
have a child and I don't see why you got
to do so much Arrangements just because
you guys are not together that's the
only thing that's that's different yeah
my mum and dad as well because my mum
and dad broke up when I was well they
got divorced sorry should I say when I
was four but obviously my dad's always
been there and even if we like go to
parties people still think my dad's my
mom's husband they're like no no no I'm
married again and all that they're like
what you got married again like yeah
like it's that's how like tight they are
they're good friends
it is because even right now my my
daughter's dad doesn't do as much as
he's supposed to do and I have a lot of
people behind me saying oh you should do
this you could you should call CSI and
this and that but
child maintenance on him or whatever
and and all of these stuff and it's just
like I know I can but I choose not to
because it doesn't make it doesn't make
sense to me I have a question why did
your parents separate if they got along
my parents I was young so I can't answer
that what about yours my parents that do
hot hits that move they're both Jamaican
they're just all-headed they can't be in
the same room ticket one like today like
nowadays like they can speak they speak
on the phone they like charges but back
then I think it's because like more so
like
it was like I'm the first child in it so
it was just like cool and then they jump
they're both Jamaican as well so it's
just like oh hey like you come I don't
know you can't put two
you can't have two Alphas yeah
especially you get it yeah because my
mom's a problem
were your mom's feminine would you say
Mama's
I think that some people won't say a bad
word about their mum so I appreciate you
being like my mom my mom's like like the
charger you get like my mom's like
brother sister relationship it's not
like a mum and Son relationship it's not
you know I mean so it's like even even
in then like my grandma like that's my
mom obviously when she passed then I
found out my mum was my mum you get so
it was like I grew up with my mum no no
my mom as my sister so we just continued
to this day to be like oh yeah like
that's my oldest sister or whatever like
that's how it is I agree she don't even
allow me you thought your mom yeah
so I was told like wait what do you mean
like like I just assume you just had the
same thing happen no I'm guessing
because she had you at a younger yeah at
a young age so I also I like when she's
going to college and she's going uni I'm
there chilling with my grandma I'm
assuming that my grandma's my mom and
then she's coming back I'm like yo
what's up sister and all of that stuff
you get it took until my grandma passed
away for me to deepen say raw that's not
my mom that's mine you get my grandma
whatever but it's more so like
it's more so like even even just that
like my mom I can't call my mom mum in
public like it's not I can't call her I
can't call her mom in public but it's
like she preferred me not to call her
mom in public only because she's a young
parent and because I'm so I'm like with
this child like how old was she like she
my mom was uh 17 when she had me so it
was like
my mom looks young so when you see us
both beside each other I look like I'm
her man does that make sense so it was
like she don't want a growing us right
boy to be calling her
um mum in public so it's like I have to
call her back first thing whatever just
out of respect to you so it's just like
so how how was that like um how did that
affect you growing up being raised by
like your grandparents as opposed to
your mom well it was
it's not even like that we're all on the
scene it was all in the same household
okay so it wasn't really that it was
just like more so I I went on this dark
thing where
I was a good kid up until my grandma
died and then I just started going to
school like bugging out like fighting
people every day and all of that like
getting kicked out of like six different
schools yeah
um you get kicked out of six yeah like
excluded like excluded from six
different schools and it's not even just
that like I was like leaning more into
like
into like the area because I grew up in
Brixton and so in Brixton brixton's like
different from everywhere else like in
South London in general is just it is
different so it was just like I was
getting caught up in all of that
politics and stuff like but it was more
so because I I lost my grandma man and I
was my mum so it was like I'm young and
I'm thinking expressing yourself you get
it that's like that's how I'm like
referring myself and then it it got to a
point where I got kicked out my law
school and to my parents I was like
right you're going to Jamaica that's it
that's it now you're gonna have to go up
in Jamaica because we can't deal with
you and we can't have you been you know
bad and doing all that stuff so like
obviously going there now grow up
seen a whole different life like I've
seen people the same age as me and I've
seen the stuff the struggles in
Jamaicans you know seeing just seeing it
like physically seeing it with your own
eyes it gives you a whole different
perspective on life because it really I
I did how lucky and how like
grateful I am to be to be like born in
the UK to just even have a red passport
you get what I mean because in Jamaica
it's hard very hard it's so hard to make
money it's so hard to make money number
one it's so hard to even get a Visa
that's why it's a whole stereotype of
Jamaican men getting with you know
to get green cards to come over here
because it's so hard to even get over
here people have to work and get twenty
thousand dollars which is like the
equivalent 500 pounds yeah like 500
eventually they get paid 500 pound a
month and imagine a week every week they
only get probably what 150 pounds and
they think that's a lot of money but
when we told them what we get paid are
you a rich man you're rich man that's
why they think we're rich
five thousand pounds five thousand pound
over there is a million dollars yeah you
get it that's the thing so whether
they're working hard they're working for
weeks to get twenty thousand dollars to
go get a a v to try to get a visa and
apply for the Visa and if the Visa
doesn't get approved they don't get but
they don't get back that money that
money gets taken you get it so the fact
that I I I I have the best of both
worlds where I can go there and I can
come back I I'm I'm grateful so what
we've seen that me seeing that me going
to school me experiencing everybody
there made me deep everything in life
you go I mean and that's why I never
look I never looked down on anything
I never looked down on anyone you just
appreciate everything you have I'm
pleasure yeah why didn't your parents
stay together
um like I said I was young when they
broke up so I don't really know the ins
and outs of would you say your mom was
submissive to men my mom yeah no no no
no because there's eight of us I'm the
youngest of eight and they're all for my
dad so my mum stuck with one guy for
about the hard times about him obviously
if things happened and it just obviously
didn't work so they're separate but
they're really they're good friends now
no I just think it's like the root of a
lot of problems and swimming not being
able to be submissive to men because
we've been told that we're their equals
and we're not okay yeah do you agree
with that or disagree when you put it
like that yeah and men don't know how to
be men anymore as well what do you mean
by that okay
yeah they don't know how to wear their
crowns anymore I don't think it's men I
think it's how things are in like
Society like me social media like look
at for instance I said this on the other
podcast that we did like look at some of
men's clothes their jeans had a tie why
are men in skinny ass jeans and then
again you're comparing a fashion trends
sorry she's right though no she's right
like if you look walk down the street
it's like the men's clothes are becoming
more feminine yeah and the women's
clothes are becoming more masculine
stuff yeah yeah and if you look at that
clubs as well yeah so she she's right
honestly because I think they they
literally train like train each other to
be each other yeah
I disagree with that dude I disagree
with the fashion the fashion same thing
because if you I just think that's
another excuse that people try to use to
cause confusion because if you go
through all all throughout history
fashion has always changed there were
times when men were tight as clothes
yeah man used to wear heels yeah we're
all still masculine men I just I just
think that is another way why did men
wear heels 70s
they were doing the same like propaganda
so like like before 100 years ago yeah
but I'm just saying like I just think
fashion is separate from masculinity you
can be a masculine man um
when they're putting hairy styles on the
cover in a freaking
dresses
like men can't wear tight clothes I just
think that's not right because there
were even times when men used to wear
like tight ass boot Cuts where it's like
very flurry at the bottom and then it's
tight here and then they wear like
tighter silk shirts they're still like
manly men in that era as well no but
you're not good you're not getting what
I'm saying I'm saying in the sense of
when they push it out in social media
they do it in a feminine way so if a man
is going
up skinny jeans he's a feminine person
that trait about him because
realistically would you go out and look
go into Xavier and pick up a men's
skinny tight jeans and wear it what type
of skinny jeans
skinny jeans
I don't want to debate on the jeans
so what do you mean when men don't know
how to be men anymore
um I just feel what they're not support
what do men get for being men today
they don't get enough they don't get no
credit
no I mean like what do they get do they
get a good woman
no no they get status
be great did they get pulled down that's
a good answer wait go ahead can I can I
can I see something I think I think what
you what you're supposed to see is like
back in the days like not now but back
in the days men's mental health was
looked down upon nowadays men's mental
health is becoming such a thing whereas
everyone's talking about it more
rather than back in the early 2000s no
one was really talking about that now
everybody I think well I think now they
teach men to be women they teach men to
emote like women
because they say you should talk about
your feelings that's what women do
that's true I don't know I feel like
it's a thing where like if a man feels a
certain type of way and I feel that type
of way and I don't get I don't care for
a girl and I don't care if like you feel
certain type of way because I feel like
that because not really and truly as I
said if a girl is a human and I'm a
human and I feel a certain type of way
of science I should deserve to feel that
way no it's true regardless if you're a
girl or not because I feel that type of
way my point is that they tell men like
it's a how do I put it when you look at
the way they tell men to deal with
emotions and women to deal with emotions
the woman's way of dealing with emotions
is always assumed to be correct so they
always say like men you should cry more
because women cry more so they're always
assuming that like the woman's way of
doing things is correct where the men
who fight on the playground are wrong
the men that are aggressive when that's
well I'm I'm saying in in schools let's
say if if a dude cries like he doesn't
get in trouble but if they fight on the
playground they do yeah yeah and so like
the woman's like so there's a lot of
systems that I think that tell men to be
more feminine
I feel like it depends on how the guy
deals with his like you know what I'm
saying with his emotions I caught like
back in the day I'm not I caught life I
wanted to cry I'm leaving the classroom
but my point my point is like you've
never seen that in the media that I'm
saying like like men need to learn how
to be more emotional they need to be
more in touch with their emotions you've
never seen that in media nobody
like that men need to learn how to
release they need to cry more you've
never seen that absolutely honestly no
no no I've heard yeah on some Instagram
posts
up on Instagram
people like men's emotions matter yeah
they're putting that out there regarding
their mental health because like he said
it's now being spoken about more because
obviously as men
some guys sometimes you guys do find it
hard to release your emotions so that's
why I think they're kind of pushing that
out there I don't think they give a [__]
about men's mental health because if
they did if they did they would get rid
of the systems that make men commit
suicide
the way that the divorce is set up today
oh my gosh and like the fault like like
women can make one call and falsely
accuse a guy of a crime and there's
systems that support her and fund her
doing that so it's like if they really
cared about men's mental health they
would they would get rid of those
systems go ahead I had a question um for
the girls actually um if your man cried
in front of you how would you feel like
would you would you see him in the
museum the same way be honest our
complete honesty when you see him you
mean like sobbing or like you're not
gonna cry something happened to your
mama you're not crying oh exactly you're
going to be crying fair enough it
depends on what they're crying for yeah
it's about death and stuff then what if
they're like oh they're overwhelmed at
work man
stress like how would you feel
women lose respect for men
how would you guys feel yeah I would
lose respect okay thank you but for this
reason not for like something very uh uh
like as death or something I understand
yeah men have emotion but if I'm relying
on you and you're you show me weakness
on something very that should be very
like uh normal for you yeah
would you want me to respect wait so do
you not think that's when it's your
position to actually like bring him up
instead of tear him down
sorry let me not cut you off yeah so let
me say this is this is his very first
time
he's built up this tension of work
actually like getting on his nerves and
it's the first time this guy's broken
down in front of you so is it going to
be a thing where
this guy's a waste man
I thought it's gonna be like oh my gosh
I've never this is the first time I'm
hearing this baby are you okay like is
that like is there something you need to
tell me that because I feel like that's
where
I'm gonna need you to be my backbone
like that's how I feel if it's a thing
that's repeated repeated and you
comforted me and you've given me options
like you could do this you could do that
and now it's like okay I can't lie I've
tried helping you you haven't even taken
on my advice and you're still coming
here crying to me like one waste man
then I can understand where you're
coming from if it's the first time and
this guy actually feels this way again
it's human doesn't matter if he's a man
honestly I give you credit I think she's
being honest and I think that women will
cap about this so they could say what
you want to hear which is oh we don't
lose respect for you but if you're
honest the studies will show you that
women do lose respect for men when they
cry it's not to say you can so you're
gonna get left the first time you cry
I'm sure she's not gonna leave the first
time but it's like we could say what's
on it what's honest or what sounds nice
so what advice are you gonna give
someone to cry in front of your girl
that's a good idea so if it was if it
was your best friend that's a girl and
she cried about the same thing would you
react the same way of course not but
that's the thing men and women are
different that's the thing
this is it if a man cries in front of me
I'm not just like gonna let him down
just like this but in my subconscious
mind I made a little note that oh why
did he do this I mean he could have
spoken to uh a mate and yeah I'm here
for them for him like not in a way that
uh I'm not giving him like support
support yes but in my subconscious mind
I will just have this little click and
I'm speaking from the truth it doesn't
have any regards to uh the relationship
extent like I'm not gonna leave him for
crying but like in my subconscious mind
there is something that's gonna explain
it yeah
maybe like say that was his first time
crying and it's like you've never seen
him like that ever
and yeah but then you'd make a like a
mental note okay you you used to know
why we actually have a question so you
said you said but why like that but the
thing is women look for leadership so
it's like okay if you have a guy that's
the coach of your basketball team or the
teacher in a class or the leader of the
fruit like the president if they start
crying in front of you you don't respect
them the same that's not no no that's
what I mean women look to men for
leadership that's not what I meant let
me learn let me learn let me learn but
why why do women complain when men don't
show emotion why because men
why do you complaining but when we show
when we show emotion it's also a problem
no no that's why that's why you
shouldn't listen to women for dating
advice
she's complaining about uh emotions she
just seeks attention it's not about a
man showing emotion it's about the man
showing her getting giving her attention
as well not even affection like the
attention when she complains yeah that's
poor communication yeah
I actually don't think communication
fixes relationships I think it makes it
worse yeah yeah I think it gives all the
control to the woman
yeah I decided this today
yeah so if me
someone are dating right and I say
because let's be honest who's the one
that wants the communications
so then you're just constantly
thing oh I'm so happy you're here it's
always a negative and then if you talk
about the problems I think they just get
bigger and bigger and now you're
constantly changing your behavior
because you don't want to deal with her
complaining all the time and like is she
gonna be happy is she gonna say oh today
your behavior is perfect and now I'm
just super happy in this no it's just
gonna be another thing and now it's it's
just a way that women control men and I
watched a YouTube video on this today
and I thought I was like that is that's
what I thought it was true
I'm a captain of an 11 inside Squad yeah
so I've got 11 places to deal with yeah
yeah I've got 11 please to do it as a
captain I understand every single player
on the pitch therefore I know how to
deliver the message to get the best out
of that player communication doesn't
necessarily mean I have to tell you
everything but it's to give you the
right information for you to to be the
best person you can under a certain
that situational problem so I don't
necessarily have to tell you everything
but I might give you a heads up I might
deliver something in a certain way for
you to act a certain it's not
manipulation it's just to give you or
point you to the right direction because
not every person is going to act the
same I don't even I actually don't get
you anymore
do you get what I'm saying you get what
I'm saying I might say I might not give
you the full
um the full paragraph of our ABCD but I
might just to give you a and C like that
again also if you're leading a
relationship and you say okay this is
what we're doing what's the what the
communication she says okay
if the king is going to war he ain't
gonna tell the Queen the whole the whole
game plan for them to win the war yeah
you might just give them a little
strategy you trust me all right let's
call it straight bow win the war come
back
is that the majority of communications
that's what the understanding of
communication is if you don't understand
the person you're handling with like let
me okay another example you're playing
Duo you're playing um doubles in tennis
you're playing doubles in tennis if you
man don't understand how to play with
each other how are you going to win the
game yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
how to play with each other yeah how are
you gonna win the game you know
I think that you can still win the game
I think I
think at times communication is women
using problems to control men and I
think that women typically just will
give you problem after problem after
problem and in essence to control you is
it not probably and you're always going
to be running to her well I think the
majority of guys are blue pill
you know so I don't I don't think this
is the majority do you disagree no I'll
be I'll be I'll be real a little blue
film you know what I'm saying but if it
comes down to it being a ripple then I
feel like you should understand how to
oh sorry I will do the Super Chat I'm
sorry guys I forget sometimes
um all right guys make sure you like the
video all right and ring the
notification Bell and also subscribe to
the channel let me click my laptop died
earlier so I gotta go back to the Super
Chat
um also guys the most important metric
that YouTube uses I actually thought it
was likes but I think it's comments so
if you're re-watching this stream make
sure you leave a comment okay
um copper philosophy also these are not
my opinions but the opinions of the chat
so I'm very sorry if they roast you all
right
copper philosophy Pearl I'm disappointed
you didn't get any real men on this
panel Amina there is men's fall too and
women becoming feminists man's crying
doesn't mean he's weak he has emotions
you respect him anyone who thinks that
is ignorant Cooper philosophy don't ever
cry bro what's wrong with you David most
people are exposed to single-family
households or friends and families homes
that shape them a woman should strive to
be her man's peace if you're not as
peace you're failing him and he will
fail you in the end
um at juvente Simone's the female and
the yellow will be single forever she
makes the least sense and is the most
unattractive on the panel David I hate
Pearl and couch chair crew I am loving
the show I would love to know what
everyone thinks about blood screenings
before marriage to check with partner
sexual history for WOW Children's Health
benefits and risks Bloods what is a
blood screening test I think yeah yeah
okay all right because for philosophy uh
Pearl's the voice of reason Matt butcher
all she has to do is call 911 out of her
mind say whatever and you asked then try
getting out of it man is guilty till
proven innocent I've seen it many times
and it was tried on me always video
um juvented me something uh make the
woman rebuttal against the Colombian
grape story Pearl uh Jessica great
Gracia I used to think I was independent
then when Pearl said I'll run to the
kitchen and make a sandwich before I run
to the battlefield to go to war I felt
that so now it's mayo or mustard for me
Amina woman is tranquility for the man
and is the man and but the man is the
Perfecter
protector and support system to rely for
the women women and men are beautiful in
their natural way Cooper philosophy Pro
get me on here I'll tell the truth these
men are giving off big Sim fives because
of the females on the couch uh dildo
swag why would you make me say that
username
um the boy in the green jacket is
confusing survival and reproduction men
can survive without women women can't
survive without men we both can't
reproduce without each other I'm estro
something nightmares if this panel
crashed on an island what would the
power structure be and who would be
doing what Matt Butcher on the breakdown
of Traditional Values has huge economic
implications unstable birth breaks
equals too many elderly to support not
enough young young to tap money from the
U.S is allowing millions of immigrants
in to make up for it Doug MPA March 2023
they produced baby mice from two male
parents they're already taking the
ethical implications If This Were to be
applied to humans men can survive
without women Astros
esoteric nightmares hello I'm Chad GPT
about
um esoteric nightmares and program to
auto trigger on all male simps and women
overusing the terms maybe manifest star
sign my journey I feel massaging
misogyny good luck
um
um shaibez um facts don't care about
your feelings Johnny Sam's Green Jacket
put one woman and multiple men versus
one man and multiple women on an island
which island gets repopulated faster
I mean uh this Green Jacket boy it
doesn't make sense he's brainwashed Nick
roaming McQueen being on keto for seven
years conservative should be on keto and
the carnivore diet uh oh wait that's
from the last stream okay I'm gonna
refresh it just to see if there's any
more Super chats
um
and then a scout and Bradley
um would love about asking about testing
for every DNA DNA testing for every
parent
would love ask about testing every child
for DNA testing for who the parents are
um a real man does what he can a woman
does what a man can control
relationships are not equal a scout and
Bradley leadership is about is about
taking listening to all the feedback but
it's on you to decide what to do Wayne
forever
forever everyone on this podcast is
guilty as hell that's all y'all
displacing the stereo uh times per
gender
um okay I think that's all well
um so Scout and Bradley submitted a
question what do you guys think about
DNA mandatory DNA testing at Birth what
is that please
um so when you are born there's a kid
that's born they make sure the parents
are theirs I see nothing wrong I spoke
about this with one of my friends he
basically said um like if you think
about it and I kind of agreed with him
weirdly enough on it like if like a
woman naturally whoever's in her is what
it's her kid but she can't be one she
won't know who if if say she was
cheating
with her husband and some other guy she
could literally just say that it's her
husband's when it's probably the other
guys if you are guaranteed that the DNA
testing at every birth
I'm so certain that so many couples and
everything is just gonna be exposed of
Elijah would anyone disagree with it no
I agree because I feel like if it's if
if the woman is really like there's
another one or whatever then she's your
problem like you said the woman knows
yeah because we've given birth but for
the guy they like you said they can't be
100 sure nine times out of ten in some
situations there are women that have sex
with multiple partners but I'm pregnant
and they're like [__] do I say it's his
or is it his you know what I mean so I
feel like that should be a thing I
wanted to hear um I think earlier it was
like seven people raised their hand to
when they said A friend had been falsely
accused of a crime I know who did you
say did you raise your hand yeah I did
did you you didn't say it earlier what
happened okay go ahead well I know
someone I'm not gonna mention names or
anything
um why you got accused of grape
um uh it happened um you have to go
through a lot of embarrassment
um with family and friends and stuff
like that
um he didn't do it eventually like after
spending loads of money on like a
solicitor and everything like that he
got out of it and you know yeah but
obviously
um nothing happened to the girl she go
you know he she embarrassed kind of like
his life
um for like a year and a half
um his we lost friends as well
um family members like you know looked
at him differently he would speak to me
all the time he would tell me yeah man
like my uncle this my uncle that like
they don't even look at me the same when
they're in the room with me and stuff
like that and yeah
um yeah just a bit mad and the goal the
the thing is the girl after he was found
innocent and everything like that
you know the girl kind of just was
walking normally nothing happened to her
you know so yeah
why do you think why
why don't you think there's punishment
for women falsely accusing men
that's a good question
um again the law is on the woman's side
I don't know why but you know
um yeah they should be but yeah I don't
I don't know why to be honest like yeah
yeah I'm I'm curious at what age did you
guys know that the law favored women
like how young
not too late to be fair I don't know if
it's elite I'm 16 16 15 16 I think yeah
I didn't even know to like
21.21 yeah same
sadly 2020 2021 21 okay
who told you
it was even more told social media
you find out anything on social media
nowadays
I think what was did you you had a story
too didn't you yeah it was more so it
was not me be friends with anybody or
nothing it's just a story that I know I
know somebody that I knew well I knew
somebody because it's past tense and he
passed away but um
he was accused of of grape and um it it
didn't happen obviously it didn't happen
in it and um the girl was making like a
whole thing about it
and um
like it even came out that he didn't and
he was still getting bullied saying that
he did he did even though it came out
and there was no evidence there was no
you know I mean there was no like
evidence that he actually did it and he
ended up you know
but yeah he deleted himself about about
the whole situation because even after
it came out that he didn't do it
you know it ruins this whole rep it
ruined his relationships his friendships
his family all of that and that's what I
don't agree with when women do think
it's okay to do that because you're
tarnishing the guy and you don't know
what he's doing to them mentally yeah do
you know what I mean and I think women
need to be careful when they use this
word oh he assaulted me or he groped me
or like don't use that word so cleanly
because half of the time it doesn't
happen like that and you don't know what
you're doing to that person because like
it's damaged into your the guy are you
or you don't know anybody yeah he
unfortunately took his life and half of
the time this is why men are doing
anything to ever harming themselves
turned into drugs or killing himself and
it's just it's because of what I am
obviously I'm a woman because of what we
are doing and I think it's wrong and it
is it's getting me a little bit
emotional yeah it's it's sad it's really
sad because it's happened to someone
close to me like my brother he wasn't
accused of great but he was accused of
something else and it's just like don't
do that to a person because you don't
know what you're doing to him let alone
his family or how me as a sister may now
view him as my brother it's it's wrong
it I don't even want to talk anymore
because it's getting me upset but I just
I don't [__] with [__] like that at all
I don't like it what drives a woman to
do that type of thing now yeah jealousy
can I just Revenge
sorry
jealousy
um
Revenge I think I think yeah when a
woman just wants to get back at a man
but she doesn't know how to do it you
know I feel like some of them don't even
understand like how deep it is in it
yeah they don't they don't they don't
they don't like it's a thing where like
you know what I'm just gonna get I'm
just gonna get my get back but they
don't know how deep yeah this get back
is they don't know how like
um
so you think they understand the extent
they're taking us at what age though no
I don't bro
I love I like she said a lot of men are
actually very naive we like to think
we're all smarter and stronger than
women and or better than women but you
see the truth is well a lot of men don't
realize about women is that women can
just be as evil as men even worse even
worse most men just look at women like
these precious little flowers that can't
hurt to fly bruh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think they also expand the definition
of sexual assault
to really it's in everything's included
in it like it's it's literally crazy
that's what they'll do they'll take like
terms like like human trafficking right
and this kind of relates to the Tate
case where it's like if a guy you know
sweet talks a girl into bed or lies
about his uh money or lies about his job
or something like in some states that's
still considered grape can you speak
yeah now if you mislead her like there's
some law that was being the level boy
one yeah
where it's like okay you just got finite
like sometimes you take owls in life
you've got manipulated I know I know
they tried to charge state with that
didn't they so
um yeah I think it's weird man I don't
know man that's the way it was just
trying to keep him silent
so what's so words of Seduction or
manipulation yeah can be used against
the man yeah no and in all honesty I had
this realization the other day I was
like how can a man interact with a woman
and have no risk
and I was like the anxious and fearful
no I was like I can't think of a way
guys can because if you approach her she
can call you creepy you know or she can
like record it on social media and say
he's looking at me I saw I don't know if
any of you guys like saw this year this
was going on in like the London
Underground I saw like a poster on the
London Underground saying if you stare
at someone sexual assault like you
should report someone you've seen that
Bro you've seen that movie okay
I took a picture of my photo timer but
it's like a year ago maybe two years ago
but you see it yeah like it was like
sexual assault if you stare and you
should report it to like a certain
number if someone's staring at you know
what's been on the train yeah don't you
guys find that weird no it's crazy
because I feel like that's actually the
initial like that's the initial green
light when you should actually go chat
to shorty yeah
she'll look at you you look at her you
know what I'm saying if it holds for
more than three seconds then you know
yeah you know what I'm saying this so
like you're basically like it's not a
win-win yeah how do you talk to a girl
on the street without
well and then even like the girls that
are like don't approach Us in the gym
I'm like don't listen to them
how are you supposed to approach it like
this
you're really attractive
another weird thing today is pretty
privileged though an attractive guy can
come to a girl and talk about oh you are
very beautiful and she like it but for
guys weird or ugly looking it's the
guy's weird I think it's so [__] up
nowadays they're pretty privileged with
guys so I want who okay who's here is
aware of the crowd Stephen Crowder
situation she's even crowded oh yes no
one knows I'm so glad you've already
seen this clip okay okay so I want to
show you guys a clip and I want to get
your reaction to it
okay
I'm so happy I'm sorry
because it causes people are okay okay
full of glass
es
no no you just did it you're a boundary
and abusive you were not taking the car
yeah because if you refuse to do rifle
things then I will go pick up the
groceries
and we have steaks wood pellets my grill
I know it's not a reasonable
first
man
no no I don't know
so you're not taking a bus
again you are not and I will ask someone
to pick me up would you like me to ask
right it's not exactly give him an Uber
okay Stephen I can't
I can't right
like I can't see it like listen to me
listen to me you want to walk out right
now listen to me I can't go to the gym I
can't go to my parents I can't call my
friends I can't go I can't be boom
you're gonna take the car and leave me
here Hillary just think of how boxing
has made me what do you need me to pick
up I'll get it I'll be back on and back
no that doesn't work either you'll be
back when you're back either
I I understand the difference between my
life being sent to the settings
[Music]
thank you
he's sick
watch it
okay I love you
I love you very much
I don't love you that's a big problem
I've never received love from you and
the fact is when I don't look and you do
a b c and d you speak your spin that if
you go no but I love you more than life
itself okay
put on some gloves no but I love you
more than life itself that's not fair
it's not fair and it's disingenuated
Hillary you're right right now become
someone that's limited day in and day
out and worthy of a life worth no matter
the life
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not gonna engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get text me
what you need I'll get you to TV
all right
I love you
I'm committed to you
guys
do those things you're not committed to
anything you're not committed to
anything
you just said I love you walk the dog's
crunching gloves walked around here
I'm good
he's lost the dogs go on some clubs are
you committed enough to get the
medication is like don't you take take
credit
you can pause it here
so that is both a heart
okay
so just a little context so essentially
Crowder is a multi-millionaire he's very
successful he has the guy in that video
he has
um a conservative Media company right
and essentially he announced that he was
getting divorced
and in that announcement for the divorce
he said this is my fault because he he's
always said he doesn't believe in
divorce but he says you know what I
don't want to be divorced she wants to
be divorced and in the state of Texas
it's legal and this is my fault because
I picked wrong
now this fired up
um Candace Owens which I think people
may know yeah yeah so she because the
daily wire already had a beef with
Crowder because a couple months back
Crowder leaked some footage of like
basically they're in a contract
negotiation with um The Daily wire which
Candace Owens assigned to does that make
sense and um they leaked some behind the
scenes footage of their negotiations for
the contract basically saying that the
contracts were unfair so does that make
sense so the daily wire already doesn't
like Steven okay and essentially
now Candace is offended saying you're
talking bad about your wife so here is
the video that she wants leaked
now what what is your initial reaction
to the video and I want to hear from the
girls first then I'll hear from the guys
I mean do you know what it is it looks
as if he's
the fact that I think
she's pregnant
he's speaking to her like she's already
emotional
and he's sending us to do all these XYZ
things and she's not doing them but from
that video obviously we don't know the
whole context of it because if he's
saying that he's picked wrong that means
he already knew that when he got married
to her that she wasn't a woman that was
going to do things for him anyway
if he like if you stuck with her that
long and you just said now that you
picked wrong that means you kind of knew
what she was well she filed for a
divorce so I think he was trying to work
it out I'm assuming I think that's what
he meant when he picked wrong so was she
doing things for him anyway I don't I
don't know
because then maybe it's the way he spoke
with her then okay in throughout her
pregnancy because I feel like when
you're pregnant and you've got all those
emotions and stuff because I've seen a
difference with like my sister her being
pregnant and being married and
everything it's you you think pregnant
women aren't as capable of doing things
I'm just asking I think no I think
because my mum when she was pregnant she
was doing everything yeah but I think I
know it's crazy to say this but the
woman in nowadays they don't
they're a bit lazy okay okay so
um who who do you think was right and
wrong in the footage
both of them both okay
what do you think yeah I agree um
obviously we don't know what the issue
is between them two obviously like you
said he said that he picked wrong but
what if she if things was okay at the
beginning but then
what if things um was okay at the
beginning but it changed due to how she
how she was dealing with him and vice
vice versa so I don't know but I thought
that they both shouldn't have behaved
like that towards so you didn't see it
like one-sided you saw it both ways um I
well I felt the woman she was moving a
bit Ott
but um over the top sorry
um she could have handled it or
approached a situation differently but
um yeah both of them yeah wow okay
that's what about you well I think
um that's the fact that she's pregnant
um made uh the the whole scene look a
bit creepy like he's abusing her but
um in the real context
I think as well that she could have just
calmed things down rather than just like
um
like behaving and like contradicting
what he says to make it even bigger and
gain emotion because once she just
leaked the video it's for a certain
purpose you know it's to drag the
attention that's what I think because if
you you truly want to calm things down
you just can't can and then we'll have a
further discussion afterwards but I
think that it's released for a purpose
that it's not for the sake just of uh
intention yeah just for just the video
itself what about you
um obviously I think they were both
wrong in certain aspects because
obviously for her
like he was saying that when she tells
him to do stuff he actually jumps and
does it but when he wants her to do
stuff he doesn't get the same respect so
in that in that actually I agree with
him yeah like but um like she said the
reason she put out the video because
obviously she's pregnant so it looks a
certain way as viewers we will perceive
it a certain way that he's being abusive
towards her but on the flip side of it
we don't know we don't know what's
happened behind closed door we've only
seen this short clip of the video and
like he stated in the video is that if
you tell me to jump you say how high and
you expect me to do it when I asked you
to do something it's the biggest problem
so it's yeah
conservatives then took this clip and
were saying that he was emotionally
abusive
an emotionally abusive unhinged man so
what what do the guys think starting
here
I just think he was
the emotions got the best of him I would
I would have consider him emotionally
abusive of all he just simply asked him
to quote walk the dog take the dog on a
leash and didn't let her take the car if
he truly loved her but again like she
said I can't take this 20 what one
minute clip and dissect it because I
only saw a part of it right but from
what I've seen he wanted something for
her to do and being her wife she refused
to do it just because she was pregnant
but I can't wait to say too much about
it because I don't know the rest of it
um
my my take on things is like his fault
like he's throwing in it obviously we
think obviously it's a bad thing like
he's emotionally abusing or whatever
because of his tone but we don't really
know what's going on frustrations you
know I mean that's that's the
frustration that sounds like frustration
to me but from other people's
perspective it's gonna look like oh yeah
no he's just an aggressive person he's
abusing her but it's not only that is
the fact that she had her belly shown
exactly she's pregnant so yeah so in
high school it's just like a man talking
to any pregnant woman with that tone Oh
emotionally abusive yeah but if she
wasn't pregnant maybe it wouldn't be it
maybe they would not use those exact
phrases it would still be bad because
he's a man but at the end of the day but
it was all calculated to combat that
though if I'm being completely honest if
my wife was pregnant I probably wouldn't
talk to her that way I'm so glad you
said that I'm not gonna lie to you I'm
not gonna agree just because y'all agree
I gotta be fully honest if my wife
doesn't want to do something I'm not
gonna afford so that that's just me I'm
not an aggressive person I'm very I'm
y'all can call me what you want to
comments talking about but that's why I
said eventually I'm just saying I'm not
going to talk to my woman that way but
again 20 it's only 20 second clip but
I'm not gonna keep forcing someone to do
something and for example rush I'm told
to come out and film come out and film
come out and film come out and film if
he says no and for whatever reason get
the message he doesn't want to film okay
it doesn't matter what we've been we
both been through if people want to do
something I'm not going to keep forcing
it and that's just me personally the
type of person I am but obviously I
can't say anything based off a one
minute clip like I'm the same I agree I
agree we could be like I'm completely
the same like if if my woman's pregnant
like
and making sure that nothing like she
don't like she's she's good like she
don't even have to do anything because
she's pregnant I don't want anything
happening to the baby number one but
like I could understand like some random
cool they want a woman took you don't
think if he's paying like he's a
multi-multi-millionaire he's changed
This Woman's life like it like she
doesn't have to pay a single Bill work
the rest of her life he doesn't have the
right to tell her what to do
oh no no that's backwards in my opinion
that's backwards does that change your
physical condition though exactly she's
carrying another life I don't think
you're pregnant it should determine how
much he should listen
it's not even about what you want I mean
I just my point is about leverage it's
like okay you have a guy that's a one in
a minute what percent of guys can make
it so you don't have to pay for a single
thing okay
can I say something so you tell me right
now if I some if I somehow blow up I
become a millionaire you're my wife I
can treat you whatever type of way just
because I have money in status so fast
[__] come here make me food max I said
[__]
stop talking I have money now
it makes no sense to me okay you want me
to answer the question yeah yeah keep
going sorry
I I think that men have a lot of
Leverage I didn't say any type of way I
don't think you should be abusive but
because he what he raised his voice yeah
I mean what are you okay in my what do
you consider a beast what is your
definition of abuse hitting
um so you don't think muscle Beast is a
real thing I think there's some forms of
mental abuse but
um I I don't know it's hard to Define
because okay it's very broad they put
everything as abuse not that I would not
label as abuse okay I mean
telling you to walk the dogs and put on
some gloves true if that's the bar for
abuse
it was dating her from leaving the car
and going from the premises
the title to a car he pays for because
what the [__] out of here
but you said like he's providing her
with money and multi million so like you
don't think that he should yeah I don't
know what to do and stuff like yeah no I
think that if if a guy if you have a one
percent guy if you have a guy that that
is paying all your bills he can
completely change your life I think he
has leverage and you have to oh no he
has leverage but you don't have to
listen you don't have to listen number
one I think that's the problem in
societies we don't think we have to
listen to our men when you should good
luck staying married when you don't
listen to your husband she's also
carrying this child so why would you
want your child to be what does it have
to do with it she gets to carry his
child to do it like it's physical
condition exactly I mean I'm gonna say
that
but Sarah across the road might not be
able to do that you know I'm saying you
gotta know your shorty i'm saying no
woman here it's gonna run all right I
run when I was five months pregnant my
daughter's race in her school and I won
and I beat all the money
because everyone here everyone here is
not equal I'm not gonna expect you to
run 5k the same time when you're
pregnant the majority of like come on
people used to work on farms like we're
not different biologically than we were
100 200 years ago
and so it's like okay you picked a lazy
woman
pregnant I don't think we have the wrong
procession here yes being pregnant does
affect it but I'm saying I don't care
what status you have doesn't make it
right to treat a woman any type of way
just because you have money and leverage
your room so what what did he do that
was so wrong I'm not no I'm not saying
this wasn't completely wrong I'm just
saying in general from that situation
it's not a lot shown
there's a saying you can't get fire
without flame that's not the first time
he's done that right obviously the
situation she's pregnant but he's he's
still
being on that level and it looks bad
because she's pregnant and stuff but
you know what I mean it's it's in my my
same situation and I've you know I
wouldn't I wouldn't speak to a woman
that badly if they're pregnant and I
never did but I saw those red flags from
day and for my child's sake
you didn't act in it I didn't act all
right exactly but at the same time I
would
if I'm with this woman and I'm making
all the money and she keeps pushing me
and pushing just pushing me to a point
maybe it gets to a point like that but
I'm saying
could it be a point where he's always
like this don't know I feel like it
could be frustration in that because
remember the guy said they crooked that
he didn't act on it you know what I'm
saying he realized that he picked bad so
it could have been a thing where
he knows that she's probably capable of
course this could be a factor he knows
she's probably capable and she is actor
not I just want to know how she would be
uncapable of walking dogs you know what
Society we're living in we're
questioning if a pregnant woman is
capable of walking
it's not about capability though how
many months
how many months pregnant was she you
know I'm gonna say if she's like in her
last month
seven children she was able to walk a
dog
that convinced me I'll be honest the
majority of women if there's some
extreme health conditions
at the same time
no no I think okay again we're not
talking about women walking dogs 100 we
all we all know women are capable of
walking dogs you can be nine months
pregnant and walk a dog
why do you guys keep picking up that
she's pregnant I'm not talking about
she's pregnant I'm saying she don't want
to do it no I'm saying she didn't want
to do it
and that that's that's the point there
she didn't want to do it I I say leave
her alone it doesn't matter that she can
I think he was testing it out he's a bad
wife then if you didn't listen in it
he's testing her obviously that's
he wanted to do it I provide everything
you're telling me you can't freaking win
the dog okay what's what's that about
yeah it's not even just about providing
everything it's just about being a good
wife as well like you know I mean like
I'm talking like you know I'm just
generally in it if I like if I had a
wife and I told her to do something for
the best of us you know the decision
would be for the best of us and if she
said no then yeah kind of thing is it
that deep what do you mean what do you
mean the fact that he why did he want
her to walk the dog that bad it's insane
is it really in my opinion that's why I
feel like it's an accumulation
that bad yeah
was the man like I could be the woman
hey guess what she was very like no no
no no no no like she was she did she
turned out I can't even say like oh but
she always responds like but I love you
and it's like why is that even a
response to her like trying to book the
dog
that's true yeah
I think she planned it yeah
that's that's why she had her top up
yeah that she was pregnant okay so um
so here's here's the context so they
started analyzing the clip and they
looked at the time stamps of the Ring
camera and it turns out about a minute
was cut
before after
uh it was before I was like in the
middle of it it was so so basically
you're saying that she might have
basically instigated it to get to that
situation but the club came out and
conservative media went crazy
um
and that's the why do women do this
where they pull a clip where a man looks
crazy and put it on the internet to make
them know I had to make them look bad
without the context of the full
situation because he said what that he
picked the wrong woman
well wait is that why she done the video
Yeah well if you're getting divorced I
can't imagine it was the right woman
[Laughter]
it's crazy so that's the they haven't
released the full footage yet
you're going to but so then the other
guy comes forward and says fine you
wanted to do this I'm on sealing all of
our documents
so like everything in the divorce he's
unsealing I respect that and that's like
do you know what they go through in the
divorce there's like affidavits of texts
I'm like wow um mental health history
has it ever happened to anyone where a
clip was taken
um out of context of you or like
recorded
nope no not yet I can't think of that
yeah Hallelujah Hallelujah
I can't think of anything though okay
I'm gonna Read Super chats really quick
isn't that crazy though I didn't notice
the clip cut
so that hasn't been released no no but
you could see where it did because when
she had her stomach showing and then a
couple seconds it was down like if you
watch it properly you can see it was
doctored yeah but it's like we live in
this Society where it's like a 30 second
Buzz clip can ruin someone's
recommendation that's what's scary
there's no accountability for the
reaction channels or the people that
push them these 30 second Buzz Clips
without giving the full context and they
never offer a retraction ever
guy in the Hat negotiates with Force he
lacks the mental strength to persuade or
convince women to do anything sad he
ain't no pimp zero Fallout this is a
perfect example how women can divorce
um you years ahead
oh shout out to keep me in it that's a
good
ouch you know that's all I got to think
about a hikimi situation
so much for doing that honestly man put
everything in his mom's name
the mum is the man's First Love yeah
like that's that's that's just that's
what it is how do you women feel about
that though is that are you respect for
him or you thinking I was very happy
because some women nowadays only get
with men to try and get something like
I'm sorry like I think the more I do
this divorce documentary I think that
women are evil when it comes to divorce
I interviewed this guy oh my God it was
so sad he literally showed me text like
messages print because I make them bring
in the document because then people will
say they're lying or whatever so I make
them in the actual like documents she
literally said to her friend I wish he
would hit me
because she was trying to get him to hit
her
so she could take the kids and like
bring that to court even though
she admitted and she admitted to hitting
him multiple times and then she didn't
let him see the kid for a year
and then she went to court and guess who
still got primary custody
of course isn't that crazy even though
the evidence is there
yeah yeah and he's on child support too
but the world is against men do you know
what the reason they gave
was because
um she spent more time with the kid
because she hadn't seen him in a year
but she's a mother no no like um she
didn't let the dad see the kid for a
year so then the reason they gave her
the custody was because the mama spent
more time with the kid in the past year
that's true but how could he spend time
with the kid he made it that way yeah
yeah because she accused him of abuse oh
and the reason they like women so a lot
of people don't know this but the reason
girls can get away with this is they
have like an abuse system that is like
it's like a point so it's like on a
scale of one to ten let's say you have
to hit like a six in order to be labeled
like abusive and the problem is there's
different like like pillars when it
comes to abuse so there's coercive
control which is basically like you can
say oh he didn't let me spend five
thousand dollars on the credit card he's
controlling and that's abusive there's
emotional manipulation so okay he like
so it's like there's that's what I mean
when they expand the definitions to make
it a very low level for abuse
the trouble yeah and so that's why but
and that's why um in
that's why when a girl says she was
abused you always have to ask was it
criminal court or was it family court
because she could say because if she
says Family Court I don't believe her
because like because the bar is so low
for family court and if you're
comfortable to speak about it like
because they'll say I was too scared to
speak up but it's like well you did in
Family Court why didn't you go to Korea
but criminal requires evidence Family
Court doesn't okay
and so that that's like why it's set up
the way it's it's kind of crazy majority
of the time is it Family Court then yeah
and it's like 80 of women in Family
Court don't have any criminal like
there's no conviction from the police
and for those that do Criminal Court is
that actually like majority of the time
that they file for it that's it's
actually been that if they win yeah yeah
because you need evidence and and you
have to persuade a jury it's not just
one judge because you can cry in front
of one judge but a jury of your peers is
a lot harder to how comes the evidence
is not needed in a family court because
it's based on a balance of probabilities
so it's like like it's um in criminal
court it's innocent until proven guilty
yeah wherein family court it's like it's
based on a balance of probability so
it's um
it's it's basically more likely than not
so it's not in that
crazy pretty smart that is is that the
intentionally trying to make families
sex right here no I think I think
they're trying to like I think they're
trying they they tried to destroy the
patriarchy by by taking followers yeah
because who has more influence on the
next generation of others no the mothers
because fathers don't get custody of
their kids that's why I think that
that's how they were trying to destroy
like feminists were trying to destroy
the patriarchy by taking the data out of
the home which I find very ironic you're
rewarded for it you're given money
what the woman yeah yeah you get
benefits
there's like a lot of incentive
structures where it's like if the man's
out of the home you get money
that's crazy
they tried to destroy the nuclear family
construct that was here the nuclear
family is a strong family exactly and
the strong family won't allow you to
take over the world and I think they do
it because women are more susceptible to
propaganda so they can control the
population better if they control the
women that raise the man you know what I
mean yeah and that's why that's why I
think they're trying that's why I think
they're trying to take down Andrew Tate
because now he has children no he has
too much influence yeah exactly
yeah yeah
um I'm gonna continue the super chats
very sorry I'm about to get it Adam
Sutton wasn't Steve's real issue that he
didn't want his wife super pregnant
while driving
I don't know that might have been but
wouldn't that be crazy if the whole
thing was he didn't want his wife super
pregnant while driving so he's actually
looking out for her yeah that's what I
mean like you don't know
imagine if that was the reason and she's
just being stubborn yeah but it's not
talking about communication though see
he didn't say that now hit me up he
could have simply said remember it got
cut we didn't see them
Lawrence Bullock beta mail alert the
happiest Gilmore Crowder is a serious
heart condition in that clip I'm sure it
was a difficult time for both you can't
judge a marriage in three minutes Amina
I think she would she wants to be free
so she can do stuff and not be a wife I
feel sorry for a western man who's
dealing with this disobedient woman out
there if you don't fear God if you don't
want to obey your husband and be then be
free good to go to the the bars a Scott
and Bradley this video plus his co-host
calling him a diva plus lots of people
on the show were saying the same meh
makes dislike a man but likes his
content a scout and Bradley as a man if
a woman is pregnant with your kids you
act different towards her she is more
emotional I'm Don giggins thank you for
the Super Chat Marlena would you what
would your take be if woman says the
baby is his after birth should she be
allowed to put father on the birth birth
records why or why not
what would you do if the woman says the
baby is his after birth which
um I don't know I don't really have an
opinion
like can women do that can women just
say someone's the father and put him on
the birth certificate no some some
people have some people have yeah oh wow
I didn't know that some people have yeah
Wayne forever um there's tons of
pressure to be with women when when it's
not even economical in modern times but
women also feel stressed but the game
keep gatekeeping so hard and then one
more
way in Forever
um the guy in the gray is pissing me off
he has a lot to learn dildo swag why why
do you do this to me
um Ring videos only last 90 days that
video is from years ago it was planned
no woman speaks the way she does I love
you but this abuse is sick who speaks
like that
um 90 Frito pie I have it Pearl the
reason I asked if anyone's dad would be
absolved from an accusation of grape is
to show the power women have over men
once it's over it's over is anyone safe
your dad your brother your uncle t h
hi Pearl I'm 26 from SoCal and I'm
incredibly grateful for your hard work
I've struggled for a while and haven't
found a based woman role model so thank
you for the valuable content uh Marlena
she couldn't walk the dog but she could
leave to film
90 free-toe pie um guy in the hats uh
secret negotiates with Boris he lacks
the mental streaks strength to persuade
or even convince women to do anything
stamp he ate no pimp
okay
you know I don't know they're they're
going off zero Fallout
um this is oh what do you guys think do
you think she planned that divorce years
ahead now that we know that it was a
Year's old video yes sir
I believe so maybe I don't know man
again three minute video I really can't
because she has the intent to edit and
do all of that you never know maybe she
didn't plan it initially but maybe
something happened that obviously No
One's Gonna Know About only they do and
then she's like you know what I'm gonna
try and get him back and then she she
released the video she reads the video
right yeah so yeah then the step of
London because while she edits or not
I've watched a movie on Netflix where a
woman actually planned to mess up her
husband's life on purpose and she took
years to do it I can't remember what she
what I think
because her behave as a wife wasn't she
wasn't approachable like when he'll take
her out and things like that
her just
she wasn't a wife to be proud of so
obviously a man's gonna eventually you
know so I think he was cheating
it's so hard to realize okay what am I
doing as a woman for my husband to
behave like this so she took upon
herself to literally
improve and maybe see that sometimes she
ended up killing him oh wow but she
slowly destroyed his life first and then
ended up kidding him just because he
cheated but then she was a bad wife
like why would a man want to be with you
so yeah that was a scary crazy though
because we really mean when women people
always misconstrue my opinions on
cheating one it's crazy that they
probably Netflix that's like of course
the narrative gosh like of course but
it's too it's like women always talk
about like cheating right and they
always frame themselves as the victim
but it's like sometimes you did
something action yeah but it's like
sometimes you did something you put to
push him to do that and that's what they
never talk about like it's never them
that's true so that was scary
so I think that's quite quite true men
are simple man they're women women I
don't have to download the formula I I
don't know if you guys the formula
it's very simple
like there's like there's um a guy that
I know and he's married and then um I
think I must have been doing some sort
of
money business with him at the time but
um he was telling me how he was
literally
um he would cheat on his wife any time
that he can damn because she's loyal and
he knows that she'll stay oh that's the
difference
can you imagine he won't only do that
because he either
there was no love to start with and
maybe he just likes cheating well he's
just he's a Serial cheater
doesn't but then I've heard that like
not just her but like guys if they did
have the opportunity to cheat on their
wife without getting caught because I
know even now this this woman does not
know by his date oh she's watching this
she knows now
there's no name
on okay I'm I'm a singer and I sing at
loads of weddings I've had
I've had room keys given to me in
envelopes I've had the bride friggin
wait what I'm serious like it's it's
crazy but I stay true the fact that I
didn't cheat is because I was I thought
I was happy at home so I did the right
thing and I didn't do these things
so what you're saying is men cheap when
they have an opportunity to well if it's
not right
sex food and respect I'm telling you
that was the basic three things if those
are met my God my guys won't go anywhere
your girl's nagging he's gonna look
somewhere else if I know you say it's
like a a motherly thing to be feeding
your man what that's what's been done in
the past if you do that for a guy
a woman if a woman can cook for a guy
it's a plus
respect plus and where physical men are
very physical and sex is up there it's
it's that's how that's our emotional way
of communicating in a sense
if those three things are met we ain't
going nowhere but it's it's a decision
you choose to cheat you choose to stay
with your life because it's not you know
what I'm saying because it's just
something wasn't right it's simple moral
isn't it you know what I'm saying
obviously at the end of the day some man
will not give a [__] yeah they'll go on
their way to cheat they'll get the
opportunities some man might suffer and
be like you know what even though this
marriage is going completely left I am
going to stick by it do you think that
women in a way cheat on their future
husbands by not being virgins on their
wedding days yes or no um
exactly yeah but that's not what it's
like okay if you look at the things that
like men bring and women bring it's like
met women used to bring Purity and youth
right
feminine yeah but that was like in the
1600s though not really it was like
um I mean only 15 of women admitted to
premarital sex a hundred years ago so
it's actually not that far
um the you know even if they're lying
that's still two out of three I mean
it'd be amazing my future wife was a
virgin but like what one of them
you can never gonna find them wait wait
you even said that earlier what you even
said remember how I said I wanted my
future wife to have less than what five
bodies you were like that's almost
impossible to find
did I have to say that earlier yeah
today yeah today less than five no I
said I want the final woman who had less
than five bodies and you were like as
they get up in age that's hard to find
oh maybe I was talking about the older
the older um yeah oh okay okay I'm just
saying it's a hard ass to find someone
that's that there's a virgin do you know
also body code huh
it's been a while
it's gonna lie man yeah
no but I mean like to be honest but I
think that like the exchange in marriage
is like usually you get Purity in youth
right and then what do you get in return
you get resources and he he doesn't
sleep with other women in a way it's
like you're kind of compromising on both
your mating strategies because men want
to screw everything and women want to go
to the best guy they can so in a way
like I think you kind of are cheating on
your future husband in a way but I'm
about to add something to the
conversation as a man if you cannot tell
a woman's um bodycon yeah if you cannot
tell without asking her directly then
you shouldn't be committing to a woman
I'm so glad you said that because I
can't lie okay
so how's that called The Scouting Report
in it I was gonna call The Scouting
Report because guys yeah they'll do this
guys will rarely directly ask a girl in
it what their body count is but there's
a certain angle we find out our way to
know what your body count range is and
that would decide whether we put you in
the Wi-Fi category
potential category you know what I'm
saying so if your Sky report is higher
unless you're a five-star Scout then
obviously
everything into football terms
everything
obviously you know you know how to find
a good girl for you for you in it but
then if some guys tell me how do you how
do you run the scouting reports yeah
I don't know fifth date with a girl
50. I don't know how long does it how
first question how long does it take you
to run these reports it depends on what
you're talking it depends how you open
how she opens up how you can open her up
you know what I'm saying there's no real
time range to it but the more you get to
know it the more you understand when you
first meet her you might think all right
cool I'm just I just want a g but then
later on you might realize that raw I
can't lie she's not the same girl I
thought she was at the start or you can
me I promise you guys have dealt with
this they can feel oh yeah this car is
laying let's go sweet I can't lie I'm
gonna cough up wow she's she's a jazzy
[Music]
she's so cheesy
you're going back to your boys like
Amanda my foot she was the one
unfortunate
story star person you know what I'm
saying bro
it's great it's it's crazy every every
guy has a different you know I'm saying
angle different ways they understand it
it's different for every man in there
I'm pretty sure all these guys can
understand when she's on the first team
or she's on the results
but what's the girl's thing about the
whole body count situation like no no no
hold on
why do girls get offended when we ask
like why why do you get offended that's
a good question because if you guys
asked us
don't get offended I think it's when you
like because some guys will ask you on
that you know when you've like go out
take them on a date if you ask him on
the first day then I think that's a bit
wild I'm not a fan it's just like right
has that happened me yeah
um on the first day the guy asked you
that but when I did that thing with yeah
okay well that's different yeah
if no one's never asked me down if they
did I would be like I would be honest it
doesn't offend me I would be like this
this and this this that but I feel like
when girls do get offenders it's because
their body count is high okay do you
think do you think it's high or it's
just an insecurity in their body count I
said do you think it's happening because
sometimes girls okay there's a guys ask
him because they're looking for a woman
that probably more expensive if they're
not they might they may feel like a bit
or I've only probably had one and they
they may look a bit but then it kind of
it depends on the person I can't speak
for Every Other Woman why are you
laughing what's your what are you
thinking I'm just thinking like the
obvious question what's your body count
if you know I've ended no that that's
what that's my answer but the girl won't
answer what's your body can you're
asking me yeah why did you want to know
that it's interesting you see how you're
acting no but I'm not offended but I'm
just asking why I don't really want to
like why do you want to know that though
I was interested in it okay
yeah
maybe maybe he wants to ask you on a
date later
maybe what's your body shy
are you embarrassed to say I'm not
embarrassed it's less than five oh so
what number is that no no no honestly
it's less than five wow that's me being
honest yeah okay wow
[Applause]
what's the other girl saying about five
red yeah
at what body count does a girl become a
[__]
that's a good question
double digit no no
triple digits
[Applause]
but
you know we know the same ghost I don't
know
it's crazy
all right so ten she's a [__] no no no
no no no no no okay how old is she it
depends on it depends on that if she's
right if she's
yeah okay so 19 at 19 she's a [__] oh
100 wow
that's wow
25 25 she's a [__] okay here's the
reason that's a little slow ties I wanna
for real okay I just I wanna I'm trying
to nail everybody down in a number all
right so wait how old are you again I'm
21. all right so let's say a girl's 20
what what body count is she a [__]
mm-hmm
what about you I'm 20 I'm 25. okay so if
she's 23 oh my God if she's 23 and her
body comes above
careful you're sick
if she's 23 and everybody counts above
12. I'm out okay for my foreign
[Laughter]
what about you sir
um personally personally me I want a
virgin wife so
but I would say one to two I would
consider above that I would say you're a
slutman oh wow so I had three years yeah
wait wait can I answer your body kind of
if you don't mind
uh yeah sure man it's uh 10 million
but what is your body count like would
you be considered like I haven't
actually counted it okay no respect
respect that's
fine but you want a virgin but it's
different but it's different for a guy I
think so yeah yeah because guys
here's the actual thing here's why it's
different for a guy yeah for a guy we
have to try
yeah to actually have sex where a girl
can walk in right now I guarantee anyone
these women can walk into a bar but like
have sex with me and God will say what's
the catch
it doesn't matter how sexy you are as a
man yeah it does not matter bro you can
be a five out of 10 walk into the bar
hey yo free me up there will be hands up
in the air waiting 100 so that's much
higher that's why a highly body count
matters more for women than it does than
men it's it's [__] up but it's a truth
if we're gonna go on the numbers
over like five to like seven you're a
[__] because that's what because
um that's when it's like they ask these
women you know and there's a couple
different studies so it's going to
depend which one you look at but
basically like if you're a virgin on
your wedding night you have a anywhere
between like 65 to 80 chance of being
happy in 10 years so they went back and
asked the girls are you unhappily
married and 65 to 80 percent of them so
decent pretty decent odds but then it's
like around over five to seven roughly
it goes down to like 20 so what would be
a high body count for guys I've always
found this interesting
I wanna we can ask that person I want to
know what you guys is so you three she's
a [__] what about you 10 plus 10 plus 10
that's the most common answer I get ten
ten plus in it
I find the younger guys will give a
little Grace they'll go to like 15.
they're gonna have to put up with it but
anyway okay so what do you guys think is
a high body count for a guy
the women are too bothered though I know
guys are crazy it's more important for
the men though right I'm I'm guessing or
women
yeah
I mean no no I mean the other way other
way around so you're not too bothered of
a man's body count is not actually
because if it's something new and I'm
trying to get into like I don't know if
I'm actually into this guy I'm I don't
want I don't give a [__] about he been
[__] before or anything like that I
just care about the now and if you're
into me I'd I would I would think you'd
want to just give a [__] about us
400. yeah
408 this guy is out there when it comes
to Triple pies that's that's when it
comes over then I'm not trying to catch
an estate either though
I feel like if it's super high you just
start to think like why would he settle
down with me
[Music]
what are the odds me out of 400 [__]
you know what do you guys think what's a
high body count for a guy
um you you mentioned soul ties so what
what's your number
so yeah when it comes to that body count
I'd
like what she said is based on the
moment but for me it's more about soul
ties just because I've
got an understanding of it so it's not
really the body count because same way
how a female can light a man can lie too
but for me it's just more about okay can
I get a number
afraid three three whoa you I can't lie
to you if this guy's a seven out of ten
he's got more than three facts yeah so
he's got more than three
unless unless like he's he's probably in
the blood percentage but if the guy is
the top the top five percent
he's got I feel like for the guys in our
generation
hold on CC was a virgin well so he's a
virgin are you gonna are you gonna still
be as attracted to him
I know of someone who literally is with
like her boyfriend is literally a virgin
she isn't and she still literally loves
it it depends on the connections yeah
but wait say that again so I've I've got
a friend who basically like she's not a
virgin but her boyfriend is and they're
waiting till marriage to actually yeah
yeah but she'll still stay with him okay
I think that's honestly that's not
exempt Behavior
man
you're saying that like the last guy got
it for free and now he has to wait and
marry her to get it
it's a mating strategy women use it's
like they go to the church to like
Rebrand themselves basically no I'm
seriously they go to the church to like
Rebrand and like now I'm one with God
it's like Diane you have three children
like we know you're not a virgin
the whole sorry the hottest girls that
come from church back in the day my gosh
that's the place to go to pick up yeah
seven days on a Saturday
in Jamaica
Saturday
plus that's that's that's a very
dangerous situation for that guy you
know
why would you say it's a dangerous
situation for the guy the last look I'm
all about giving men good advice here
the last thing a virgin man should be
doing is coupling up with a woman
yeah no it's true I agree
demasculating masculine that's the word
a woman who is not a virgin who has had
multiple partners is very used to and
understands how to manipulate men the
easiest Target for her as a virgin
XP so that goes back to my questions
do you would you find a man still
attractive if he was a virgin
laughs I wouldn't know that he's a
virgin until we had the conversation but
when we do have the conversation and I
do find out he's a virgin I will step
back
you can realize that he's a virgin or
not but obviously by his behavior
because you can tell some men who have
it but then you there's some men you
can't tell so if I've if I'm speaking to
someone and I end up finding that he's a
virgin
that's it I don't want no problems
why do you say freedom that's too low
my needs at least more than freedom to
be fair
I've never asked my partner his body
count because I think that his passes is
why should I judge him based on his his
policy he can my preference is that but
if he's got more whatever is not going
to make a difference if that makes sense
it's just not just as long as he knows
what you like
you know all that stuff life is about
giving taking it
I agree
what about you two how high is too high
of a body count for a guy
well for me it depends on the the nature
of the relationship that this man had in
the past like if I knew that this guy
would like just like go to a bar and
let's just like um screw the first one
in his
um in his weird I'll definitely judging
based on that but if he told me that he
had um a different relationships
different Dynamics throughout age and
years and based on his age as well it
changed the whole perspective on the
thing but if we want to say like a
general statement or of someone in like
I don't know in 30 I'd say 10. it's
reasonable okay what about you yeah I'll
probably be saying about
10. is it a deal breaker for any of you
so 10 10. as in if this if it's higher
then yeah
because you've got to take the time to
get to know that person you can't judge
them on their past yeah and I I no I
don't think it's adorable but if it's
Sky High if it's over like 100 100 yeah
like what you said do you think it's
okay if a guy judges a Girl by her body
count
like well you're higher than this but if
it's a high high number then if it makes
you feel tired and you're I think men
should judge women more for their body
counts yeah yeah yeah and I also think
men should judge I think men should
judge women more I think we as women
would be better if men judged us more
and didn't accept things yeah but I
think the problem now is men except
everything except women with kids they
accept high body counts they accept
women
someone will
you know someone else okay the girl that
was wild in that whatever School you
were at does she have a boyfriend that
way you know she does yeah yeah
go to what you said and because you know
how we said earlier the majority of guys
are a blue pill and obviously if you're
blue pill annual beta male and obviously
you're gonna accept certain things
because you ain't got you ain't manner
of boundaries you might have walls that
certain certain criteria that you decide
to live up to you know what I'm saying
there's certain guys that might rap a
body 20. and some of them might just be
anything but then some might have a body
cut of 20 but then he makes sure that
all 20 of them are like
solid like eight uh you see what I'm
saying so there's so obviously like as
you said like some might settle with um
um girls that have stupid body counts
and being an ex situation or my
situation so I can't I'm not gonna
counter that one there so
just look at that
yeah that's my dinner right there for me
to read this list to you guys okay good
so this is a read a list of red flags
that women I've started creating and I
just like to say as a group if you have
anything you want to add to the list of
like word these are words that women say
that are red flags okay
so these are words we shouldn't say
anymore partner horoscope signs I'm
looking for a connection
energy trauma toxic masculinity my truth
healing my narcissistic ex-boyfriend my
abusive ex-boyfriend great accusation
accusations don't judge yeah but
manifesting equals I want to do no work
and still get the outcome as a woman we
know your gender [__]
um I did too much and I let him walk all
over me equals I love cheaters and toxic
men and I will choose them and be toxic
as well and not admit that I had any
part to play except giving too much
generational trauma I make the same
mistakes that my parents made and I'm
too dumb to learn from their mistakes
and instead I will make the same mistake
and blame it on them in my feminine
energy men always stare and approach me
I will be submissive for the right man
men are trash equals I take no account
accountability for the negative part
that myself any woman really plays in
relationships he needs to make six
figures equals I have no emphasis on
character I don't need a man but I want
a man my ring needs to cost this much
Financial abuse I became feminine I need
a man to maintain me we need to Vibe I
am a traditional women when I am single
Manish I will be submissive for the
right man who hurt you internalize
misogyny we are leveling up together I
need a man to be on my level boss babe
I'm a bad [__] these men are broken
dusties I am the table I'm a 10. he
needs to add to what I have going on in
my life not all women equals that is a
problem with women but I won't admit
it's a problem
um I need someone to match my energy
broken men men are F boys
um when you say ask her what she brings
to the table she says I am his peace my
body my choice he hits me he hit me
harder than I hit him body positivity
manifesting I am not plus I am not fat I
am plus size or thick small all the
energy my ex was a narcissist I am a
queen and who hurt you
you guys have any you want to add
someone
I will add one thing for a big red flag
is if a girl has no respect for them own
mother when i s this is this is I've
seen it straight away when a girl has no
respect for their mother
that was the biggest fit flag for me and
from then on I knew it wasn't going to
work out but I stuck at it basically but
if you haven't got respect for your
mother where the [__] do you fit in
she's probably watching this live stream
punching air right now
yeah
I do have a list of the things we could
add to our vocabulary if you guys want
to hear that you know just for fun I
trust you I support you whatever you say
thank you I have your back I'm making
blank for dinner tonight honey I believe
or I think what can I do for you how can
I help I'm proud of you I believe in you
I couldn't do this without you I need
you I love you I miss you I care about
you I want you I admire you
oh God I don't want to read that one no
read it read it
get in the bedroom and drop your pants
before you go to work
um you inspire me um thank you for
working so hard I'll let it go it's not
a big deal
no no that was for foreign
there was a point about obviously they
said like women was saying oh yeah I'm a
10 out of 10.
is out of the women here what would you
rate yourself in well my tattoo says
Perfectly Imperfect so I am not perfect
there's no such thing as perfect that's
true and this sums me up I'm perfectly
imperfect I'm perfect to myself so what
number yeah
um I would say
I'm probably like
a seven
okay yeah because there's no probably
when we're going to be changing their
answers now that it's kind of like no I
was going to say 7.5 for myself okay
yeah we have the two ladies
all right myself because it's a
perspective of the other
artists
if I write myself I would rate myself on
my behavior on my values
I mean I don't I really don't have a
number I think you did I should be
around the bush straight forward I I I I
agree with what is what you said here
what no I agree with what like beauty is
in the eyes
people tend to find the same things
attractive in general like if you look
at dating apps I'm not the same extent
what not to the same extent like someone
can perceive uh a girl like does anyone
think that it was really a ten nope
okay you why can't we call this a fat
when the live streams why she's fat
bro be honest bro it's okay it's okay
what's your last way of yeah
that's the same thing
yeah she's overweight yeah
[Music]
if your heart if your body massage
this is the problem in society you're
contributing to the problem because the
problem is men tell us what we want to
hear not the truth and then we get these
biggies and we think we're hotter than
we are and we think there's no scale you
know and it's like this crazy world but
you know what I just let's let's rate
lizzo you know
I want you to say with the picture on
the screen if you think she's fat or not
oh my God yeah yeah no so if she is
lizzo can we get is it blubber come on
come on
I need I need there we go
that's right exactly yeah
I just I when I hear nonsense on the
show I just need to show it so
respectfully you know
um but so you see these pictures here
are you asking me to be canceled brother
she's overweight
please please
okay I need you to it's lizzo fat yes or
no she's overweight that's not the
question if you're not gonna deal with
the questions like you're not we're not
this is it you have to answer the
questions I ask you if you don't want to
answer you can go oh
you have to answer the questions I asked
is she fat yes or no
Checkmate she's in the most polite way
in the most polite way in the most
politest way I can possibly say it I'm
gonna see ya
but like thank you thank you that's it
she's overweighing in my opinion why was
this so hard she's like because 100
pounds this is like pulling teeth
clips clips online and stuff like this
yes what show did you think I caught
with whales on this show where did you
think you were coming
I didn't know
yeah
um okay you you said one to ten right we
can't we why can't we rate ourselves I
don't understand this like we can't you
don't think there's objective Beauty in
the world
no I think that I mean the person who
sees me would be able to write me better
than I rate myself because I can because
having a false construct of who I am
like maybe over ego or underestimating
myself it's not objective uh whereas if
I get a man like I'll I tell a man or a
woman like what do you think I like give
me a number but I'm asking you like one
to ten what do you rate yourself
this shouldn't be so hard yeah like we
answer the questions I ask so like one
to ten what do you what do you rate
yourself
eight eight okay okay
yeah I actually agree with you
um what would you um
one to ten what do you rate yourself
six and a half or seven depending on how
we're my hair six seven
and then you did you I said 7.7 what do
you guys think is a celebrity that is a
seven
what do we think of celebrities like
who's a celebrity that's a sub and a
woman
um
today or when she was younger today oh
yeah it's about today update she's old
as hell now
I don't know
[Laughter]
what do you guys think Ariana won the
ten
surprise
do you guys agree with that rating seven
or would you put her high are you guys
team yeah
um
[Music]
what about JLo now
she looks really good for her age I
haven't seen those posters on the
Underground
do you know who Jenna ortiga is yeah
that's Wednesday
exactly I just can't see that she looks
she just looks like a little kid this is
true like even though she's playing
adult roles and she's 20 well she's 20
or something
she looks nice
do you guys think you're equally as hot
as Jenna Ortega
equally yeah well because she's a seven
year we take him are we talking face or
like body
yeah I think I've got a nice body just
saying
so why did you say she was a seven what
do you think what do you guys go for
first face or body guys oh it has to be
a good balance
okay no our first appearance I'm on a
tube I'm making I thought eye contact
with the girl imma look at her face
first obviously but once she stands up I
can't check out the body if the body
doesn't match her face then it's like um
it's sad but it really is true I'm
looking more for what she's wearing as
well
yeah
of course the creep like if it's really
bad bro if your shoes are really bad
like Crips or big thing for me bro you
get it so if I'm if I'm gonna be with
you bro and your preps are looking like
some alligators what if she just broke
body
body than face I'm leading with face
face somebody hey who's an inch Warrior
it's about the shape what about the
girls looks
money
or looks money status is that what
you're looking for power
I was thinking height but that kind of
goes into looks looks money
oh they have loyalties that their looks
money loyalty you pick too
okay
[Music]
money and no because listen
because an ugly guy will cheat on you
too
she wants to cry on a Ferrari she
doesn't want to cry
looks money or loyalty oh loyalty money
okay loyalty and money okay you got an
ugly hands okay girls girls we're going
that way okay what about you
loyalty and
money because
uh looking money look somebody you'll
get rid of the Loyalty no because men
cheat if they have the period if they
have the opportunity they would cheat
they just don't cheat if they can't if
they don't have the options but if yeah
[Music]
um well in this generation of money now
for myself
for myself yeah yeah
um
I would hope loyalty and
probably
looks
so you'd rather do a broke a broken
no no this is the unit too I know but
you can't always use that narrative and
say they live at their mom's house and
they're broke of course yeah they do
we're in London the cost of living time
they can live outside of London you
can't always push that narrative to say
oh because for instance someone so this
is the question what did you mean what
did you mean by money as in like they're
rich or as in like do you get you know
what I'm saying you get two you get um
he's broke okay so his brother he's
broke or he's got money yeah all right
but then if you're gonna say that that
obviously everyone's gonna say money
like nobody wants anyone that's broke do
you get what I mean No One's Gonna Go
for anything you'd be a surprise it's
good looking though because I've asked
they say they'll take care of him as
long as he's hot you'd be surprised
I'm asking you a question what my boy
Theo asks like people for his videos and
stuff like that and he's always asking
girls like
does it matter like if a guy has money
like what I know wait hold on sorry what
wrong wrong thing wrong thing how much
money does it take for you to date a guy
like how much money does a guy have to
be earned I'm about time for you to be
dating them
I honestly like honestly that's a good
question that's a good question how does
she know how much the guys yeah like she
was making how much money does he have
to be making I'm off time to be there
but how was his money has nothing to do
with me
right no because it's a simple question
how much does he have to be making for
you to be there please answer guys just
give him a number more than me which is
like a pound
so you're telling me if he makes a pound
a month you're gonna stay with him yeah
wow wow
it's not alive it's not alive because I
I've I've been in it and I've done it
for three years so I'm saying it's not a
lie
sorry what is the guy okay
and you were willing to obviously stick
at it but he's the one who wanted to
work on himself okay girl I got it I got
it so money doesn't mean anything to you
because because people will say oh money
doesn't mean anything to me but you're
telling me if he makes a pound a month
for the rest of your life that's not
gonna bother you and it bothers but it's
about willing to understand do you want
to change it do you want to change your
statement do you want to change it
because in my head why would you make
that mistake twice because it clearly
didn't work last time so why wouldn't
you go for something else
his Finance is not my finance yeah but
do you want to be with a guy that's
irresponsible you're you're what how old
again that is 30. so you're 30. you want
to be with a 30 year old guy that makes
a pound a month I think at that point
that's just a life choice you'll
basically being his mum you're looking
off you're also the guy also carries
those habits as well I have my own money
yeah you have your own money but I'm
sick you can't travel you'll see you
have to use your own money to look after
another man I can't even imagine like
because when you were describing your
relationship before I didn't realize you
didn't have a job but so when I was
talking about three years I won't talk
about my husband
okay okay I just can't imagine like
being able to submit to a guy that has
no job
that's why I said it's about
understanding because obviously if you
are willing and looking to pursue
yourself and grow that's different
however if you have a pound and you're
not trying to do anything about it
because a pound can change you can flip
more but how are you guys how are you
guys going to hang out so like if you go
no I'm serious if you go if you go to a
restaurant you like you can't afford to
go chicken wow you're paying for
everything
right but that's the thing I was working
my my my work role was different I was
always working so for a man to do stuff
for me and all these little stuff yeah
we'll set dates to go out and stuff but
I'm not looking on a man for anything
it's not until now that I've got a child
and stuff finances
are more care about a man putting making
his input but before I wasn't watching a
man for his finances because I was
always in my own maybe that makes sense
maybe you should a little bit
maybe it was just fake that maybe that
guy that you had before I think he
needed a woman like you in his life to
kind of direct him like sometimes in
life we meet people
just to teach us something oh yeah 100
yeah I feel like you was I feel like he
needed you at that time so what all
right just to get this not to go back so
now now I would obviously you have to
each of them will all have to be
accountable for ourselves so he needs to
earn at least more than a pound but
before my mindset was different okay
I asked you a simple question you told
me about now you change it yeah
if there's understanding can you please
just keep the right course nothing
nothing okay okay just let her slide we
let us fight we let that slide so you
just have to be able to let her Cap all
right any one of you look next how much
to how much money does it like how much
more than me
well so if I was to make 2K a month
ideally he should make two two five or
three anything more than me is fine okay
that's that's the first thing yeah yeah
so how much should a woman be earning
mentally we just like we just can't
physically like allow like I don't know
if you man could agree on it that's me
personally yeah yeah I can't speak for
these men but me personally I can't be
letting a woman look after me like like
financially insured I have to help her
out okay if we can't do 50 50 then it's
gonna be me but I'm not gonna let her do
a whole 100 I mean you know what I mean
that's that's wild so use your statement
with the whole pound but what if what if
a situation changed and you ended up
crippled and
music there's
um there's all type of benefits you can
earn like that I'm still you know I mean
you still can make money so that's yeah
I mean you can make money on your laptop
exactly we make money on our laptops
anyway I'm well yeah yeah anyways like
I'm not sure if you can
so you make money on your computers
anyways you make money from your phone
so what makes a difference if you're in
your wheelchair anyways that's the
generation we live in now yeah you get
okay so you'll date he has to make more
than you how much CF to make he has to
definitely be making more than me
um well if I
figure
you don't have to say how much just just
you don't have to say how much you make
how much do you want him to make yeah
say a number just one number annually
well I have 40K minimum okay yeah
wait a month
because this is like my I cannot
downgrade myself from things that I'm
used to on myself being alone not being
with someone if I'm with someone he has
to be if he has to provide something at
least at the same level or better that's
that's how I was raised that that's how
things even that 40K that's that's way
above the average and average is what 20
26 20 26 yeah so that guy has worked
that guy's work so you're you're
striving for someone else
[Music]
myself able to make more than average
the amount of dating should be above yes
the average is 35 000. I was about to
say that you know okay that's probably
my second half of my age I used to be
that though it used to be there yeah
okay 35. yes okay 40 000 pounds zero you
said two five a month
well I'm rough two three two five a
month
yeah about that yeah okay well annually
obviously around 35k so I know that yeah
okay uh what about you
I thought I answered I said more than me
yeah yeah okay number
um
yeah
let me think because I've got to be
realistic because if I'm getting married
to this person I kind of want like a car
in it
what car do you want no because if I can
get that for myself
like with my money
how old is the girl that's my question
how old is the guy because my thing is
like one of you just graduated uni like
guys gradually like but they aren't
going to make 35 go for someone who's
graduated uni I'm 26.26
or above
I'll probably do like I think
30 no not even 38 39 40K I'd say minimum
85 to 40K yeah
okay you guys think that's reasonable or
unreasonable yeah I think that's
reasonable I think that's reasonable
okay I think it's unreasonable because
women nowadays want men that attractive
40 km 40K a year all this and that but I
feel like if it really came down to it
and we were on this podcast an
attractive guy came to y'all and had a
pure heart and made 30k a year you
wouldn't be like
um actually I like a guy like 35k tell
me right now that if y'all saw a guy
right now who really loved you who made
30k you you turn them down
you turn them down right now because he
doesn't make the 5K you guys want
all right
if he's got killed but I didn't say that
it has to be like oh sorry I didn't say
it has to be that dead 35 but above like
30 30. I'm not saying I'm not saying a
homeless person but there's men on here
doing their thing with uni degrees
making money but they're not making a
40K because it's tough idea I have a
question raise your hand if you would
date a bus driver
feel that
um
the way a man attracts me it's different
I mean I have a set of Standards to be
attracted to a man but that's how I am I
cannot generalize it for people
you know that right so why would you not
accept
that's not her preference
so then it's a social worker because so
it's okay we're just asking why yeah I
status in man
's how something that I'm attracted it
makes sense it makes sense it makes
sense but my thing is what they're
saying is that I'm not I'm not thinking
of you don't take it I'm a nice person
um you said if someone makes 40K right
you didn't State their job and obviously
a bus driver makes 40K sometimes they
even make more why is it because he
drives a bus
is that a frowned upon no that's that's
what that's where I said that I like
status in man like on top of yeah but
okay let me flip it again he he could
also be a bus driver but then at home
have the another job on the side but
that's his because no I'm just saying
men you can have two jobs
and maybe he doesn't want to tell you
what his other job is he just wants to
see how it is because you've already
shot him down he's gonna be like you
know what I've seen how you are as a
person
this goes to my point yeah with with
Society nowadays a woman could work in
McDonald's a guy can work in McDonald's
also yeah
a guy can walk in and go talk to a girl
a guy with money you can go talk to a
girl that works in McDonald's and
there'll be no problem right a girl
could do the same to a guy but she won't
chat to him just because he works in
McDonald's he can have the nicest car
tonight but because he works in
McDonald's he won't do it yeah that's
what you just do you know it is
a society and that's why man's world is
very competitive because and that's
because of us yeah because of something
that you've yeah said like but that's
what you just said you just said you're
interested this and I take uh like full
accountability of what I said and if the
man reacts in a bad way I don't blame
him but this is one of my choice I like
men with status that's something that
turns me on that's it I mean
I'm being honest here what what if he
owned the bus nice then would you be
interested or now if you owned the bus
[Laughter]
would that change it or no
maybe
so you want something that sounds juicy
basically you want something that like
when you're with your friends
what about a plumber a man does this a
plumber
would you not do any of the trades then
because that's what it is trade I mean
you're being honest I think like I
appreciate you being honest but no no
trades I don't think so I've never dated
[Music]
you know champagne coming fireworks
he was a dustman he he done that and the
girls all around him stuff but as soon
as obviously they've got personal and he
started to like to go and he told the
truth
she dropped him
his arms that's what he waits for so
long because he you know that's his
fault though why because he's he's
attracting the wrong females that's
correct I mean exactly yes
all the time that's true the way you
step up and the way you draw shorty yeah
you have to listen
money make sure you keep that up and
make sure you like who you are winning
you know what I'm saying if you're
coming to someone that's genuine and you
know that could be understanding and you
can do that then you know that yeah you
can she'll mess with you you'll go into
the club you're going to Libs you're
slapping bills on the table what type of
God you think will draw into your team
want free drinks I'm so I'm I'm so
surprised you wouldn't do any of the
trade because I've always my mom always
told me to go for trades guys because
she said you know how to do it like yeah
yeah and like she just said they make
good money they're usually responsible
so it's really do you feel like that too
you wouldn't date um a guy in the trades
no I would oh you would but just not the
bus driver no no I didn't say anything
about bus drivers I thought you said
earlier you wouldn't no I didn't I
didn't raise the hand because I didn't
know how much they made
oh okay but my friend's a bus driver so
but I never asked her like I wouldn't
ask anyone how much they're making it's
not really me okay
um I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second then we're gonna close out the
show I wanted to say something I'm sorry
for women that go for men
um that
is mostly for status if anything ever
happens whereby there was like some
crazy [__] that happens and the world
goes to [__] huh you women are going to
be in a lot of trouble
because then it will become survival of
the fittest
um okay thank you
I'm talking
I'm Scout and Bradley flash thing
doesn't equal status or money true money
doesn't flash around Amish
um they look for body face not character
LSAT okay can we just be real chat men
like looks like it starts
with females too yeah yeah
can we just they're they're
I hate it when the comments will come
forward and be like Oh character okay
everyone's a little superficial at first
let's just be honest Levy okay men um
can't call her fat waste buy a plant and
live alone trappy dog all the men on the
panel are affected by the phenomenon
known as pussification I'm sorry Dawn FX
high body count um means elevated number
of short-term relationships or one night
stands somebody can have a low body
count with lots of experience admonish
men and women should not cheat it's
wrong but God allowed men to marry four
women but women are allowed to marry one
man the truth is always bitter um trappy
dog body count is an indication of a
woman's ability to choose effectively an
important skill set for a potential wife
um trappy dog
these two things one paternity should be
established at Birth whether married or
single to mandatory uh child support
should be abolished three cash
assistance by the government for women
to have children that should um for
women to have children should be
abolished Lawrence Bullock before my
brother got married he thought his
wife's body count was sick she cheated
on him in marriage counseling he found
out it was 26 I'm there divorced Pearl
read the real list of red flags did
earlier old Forester I want to hear a
stat feminists of void like the plague
for far more males are born but we die
so much much more by age 40 we're
outnumbered by females
um a scout and Bradley Chicago is on a
dump fire right now please don't come
back home Pearl I am next month you know
catch me watch it Wayne Wayne forever a
guy in the gray is pissing me off he has
a lot to learn oh I read that already uh
Let me refresh it really quick just to
see if there's any more and then
Jacob the girl attracted to status do
you think there's a such thing as a guy
who has status but does not have money
Doug MPA um single moms have no room to
reject bus drivers a scout and Bradley
flash thing doesn't equal status or
money true money doesn't flash around
um what do you what do you think about
what he said um do you think that there
is such a thing as a man who has status
but he doesn't have money
in certain circumstances maybe it's not
associated to the amount of money
because as you said like someone from
another field could make much more money
than someone with status but it's just a
personal preference I didn't say that I
have like an amount of money that a man
should make
I mean yes I've said like 40 but maybe
someone with like with status would make
40K and someone with no status would
make 80k or 100K but I would still go
for the 40K with status this is just me
this is just how I see things and uh
that's it that's that's fine
um we're gonna do final thoughts
um so any final thoughts you guys have
on the show
you know Instagram I know you guys got
following so you feel free to plug them
now
um starting here and then go around then
we'll do second row
I'm making my social handle yeah
whatever whatever things you want to say
today okay so
final things I want to say
guys just don't judge everyone
like honestly you'll find the right one
when it happens like everything is
literally on God's timing just trust and
believe that enjoy yourself and the
right one will be there for you okay
okay
just say it I think that there's not
someone for everyone you don't yeah
because there's more there's more men in
the world than women or there's more
women in the world
I believe if that does happen at one
point because you know how men are
allowed to marry four women oh but then
they have to treat every single woman
the exact same I think that rules some
I'm not gonna yeah
the majority of men historically have
not reproduced so I think that sounds
nice but you know just sorry I'll
achieve it it's probably gonna happen at
some point when literally because it was
there's going to be more women on earth
than there is
yeah and they'll keep reproducing with
like the same men
will become lesbians
[Laughter]
um go ahead or did you have your social
media oh yeah so my Instagram is f s m i
n d s t a f s Mensa
that's the handle there
go ahead
um one thing that has opened my eye is
yeah we females have a lot of control
that we don't need and we're not
entitled to and
um yeah it's just an eye-opener and I'm
happy to meet all of you guys and thank
you for having me Pearl
um my social handle is motherly Garden
so that's
m-o-t-h-e-r underscore
g-a-r-d-e-n that's my buddy's Garden
I will thank you Pearl for having us
tonight uh it's always great to hear uh
thoughts of many people and see uh how
different people think and there is
always like a an added value and yeah to
to different subjects and
um uh if you want to follow me on
Instagram it's yusra underscore b-e-n-s
and thank you again
um my final thoughts are it's been
really eye-opening today and I feel like
women yes we have a lot of control but
don't abuse it and do not force the
accused men of things that they haven't
done because you can damage that person
and also damage their family with
circumstances and
um if you would like to follow me on
Instagram it is aries10 underscore XO
all my other socials are linked in my
bio and my YouTube channel is Aries dot
X I will be uploading videos soon thank
you
um thank you for having me on the show
um it's my first time and it was good
man good talking to everybody
a very fun conversation I could do this
for the whole day honestly
um interesting learning about different
people's perspectives and uh yeah thanks
so much
I'm [__] yeah
um yeah shout out to Pullman um the
pregame show for premium we'll see this
is my first time being like basically
being on a podcast tonight so shout out
to you Lord um I liked it hey
everybody's thoughts I enjoyed hearing
everybody's thoughts you know
um I may have waffled a bit but don't
take it serious don't take it serious
um I'm a content creator I do funny
videos online so if you want to follow
me on Instagram or um on Tick Tock it
would be r90 official on all platforms
anyways but yeah I guess it's my turn I
just want to say thank you Pro again for
having me great time it's really opened
my eyes to hearing all this different
stuff that everyone's talked about and
especially with the women and the men
situation but again if you want to
follow me on Instagram it's Kobe
k-o-b-i-e underscore Jordan
like the basketball player but with the
eye okay
go ahead
um I can't live
I thought
my mind was going to be a bit sweeter to
a few different things but I guess it
was more just on how social media
affects um
boys and girls and relationships and
stuff like that yeah but um uh catch
more socials shatters Academy my Tick
Tock people and that um my socials is
gaffa so g-a-f-f-a the genius I know
you'll catch my Instagram attached to
that as well and I appreciate you having
me on the show today
yeah
again uh I'm sure everyone thinks about
thanks for having us Pearl on this show
big After Romeo the plugger
as well
um
yeah my final thoughts
uh you know I I value everyone's opinion
on on things it's it's good to to see
this generation's 20s 30s 40s and the
way they're thinking and how positive
you guys can be
um
but yeah if you want to follow me uh my
actual socials is the RnB singer UK
um but I also have my own agency so if
anybody's getting married out there
uh married or any corporate events or
any sort of um party me I want to go
please come along you can follow me I'm
ready
you can follow me on agent r b and
that's on all socials thanks for having
me
thank you guys for coming
um a couple of now
before we end the show
two clips channels we already know go
subscribe to both also
guys we have some meetups coming up in
London we're gonna do I think we're
gonna do something at flat iron grill we
were thinking again
uh the 13th because I go to America the
15th so we're gonna invite we're maybe
even gonna do like um what do you call
it like singing or something from the
old guests and whatever so I don't know
but sign up for our Google form list
um to be notified for that so make sure
you sign up and put your email and your
phone number that way we can give you
guys
notifications for when we are going to
be doing meetups and we're doing some in
the US too so if you're in the US make
sure you sign up as well also guys do
our fourth membership tier to get a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
can give you a lot of insight into
running a podcast how to recruit how to
you know run production just a lot of
podcast stuff make sure you like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and go subscribe to our three
talents now um so I'm Miri we really
want to get a married to a thousand
um subscribers so you can get monetized
so make sure you go subscribing he's
been working so hard this man did like
uh like 30 reactions in like two three
days this man's grinding so make sure
you go subscribe to his channel Auntie
Jenny and King Richie's like the video
on your way out and I'll talk to you
next time
[Applause]
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
foreign
with you I think they do do it for the
men but it's like sexual tension it's
not really relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from them than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though but it goes
so deeper though because I know what
you're talking about and he has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
bat her great body doesn't look good to
a man but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest under School women for
women so like the women have higher
beauty standards to me yes and that's
what's making women feel like they need
to comply with these standards who's
picky or men or women men women are more
complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept more than men do you think men
are very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry it
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last oh I I done
an only fans but it wasn't like designer
boobs it was lingerie yeah builds right
whatever I'd done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not coming if you
don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not a high
respect for yourself